this is jocko podcast number 260 with
echo charles and me
jocko willing good evening echo good
evening
so i was
in my bedroom
sitting on my bed and i was
wrenching in pain
or i guess the proper word is anguish
it had been two days
since seth died
and the the five stages of grief were
not kind to me
the first stage of grief denial was over
in about 15 seconds
i've had so many friends die that
i know without question what it means
i know how quickly it comes
and i know that my friends in our line
of work
including seth
we dance with death all the time
and just a day prior one of my friends
and mentors
in the seal teams master chief mike
fakady had died
and all this was taking place right on
the 11th anniversary of
mikey mansour being killed in action in
ramadi on september 29
2006. so denial didn't last long
and neither did the the so-called
bargaining
stage
because i know there's no there's no
bargaining with death
i know what it is i know it is
irreversible
irrevocable and i know it's 100
[Music]
final
which brought me to the next two stages
which hit me at the same time
hard
working together in unison to torment me
anger and depression
so that's what i'm feeling sitting there
in agony
and the walls are closing in and the
darkness is taking over
my brain and i can actually see it
happening
i always talk about being detached so
i'm i'm detached and i can see it
happening
and it doesn't feel like there's
anything i can do about it
i see i see hope and i see the
the fun and the joy and the laughter and
i see life
circling the drain
and i know it's bad and i know
i know where that leads
i know that that's the beginning of the
downward spiral
then i can feel my mind getting sucked
into that vortex
[Music]
and i don't know what to do
and and from my bed you can see
through the door to my office and i and
i look into my office
and gonna see a book and it's a book
that i actually wrote
the book that hadn't even been released
yet it was
about to be released
but i had received my box of copies from
the publisher and there was a stack of
those books
sitting on my desk
and i i remembered
it was like my own book was talking to
me because i remembered
that i had written about death in that
book and and when i had written about
death
i had written it for other people
because i'd experienced a lot of loss
lost a lot of friends
so i was writing about death so other
people
could learn from me because i felt like
i was good and i knew how to handle
death
except at that moment in time i wasn't
handling it too well
at all
so i picked up the book
i picked up the book that i had written
i picked up the book
and opened it to a section
to read the words that i had written
myself
and i read it
the section's called death
and it says how does good apply to the
worst
of losses the death of a loved one
it's easy to think that there's nothing
good in death
but then i remember the people i have
lost throughout my life
the memories of them the experiences the
fun
their unique personalities and
everything they gave me
not only in their life but in their
death
what their life taught me and what their
death taught me
the mark they had left on me
and i realized there is good
[Music]
even in death there is good first of all
i was lucky enough
to have had that person in my life even
if it was only for a short time
too short a time at least i got that
those those moments those precious
moments those
unforgettable memories at least i got
those and got to experience
those times to know the beauty of their
personality their attitude
their outlook on the world
they were all unique and i am thankful
for the opportunity i had to interact
with them
now comes death death is horrible and
death is wretched
and death is cruel
and death isn't fair
and i don't know why the best people
seem to be taken from us first death is
also
inescapable
there is no way out
no one gets out alive
death is part of life like the contrast
between
the darkness and the light
without death
there is no life
and the people that i have lost they
taught me that
they taught me how precious life is how
blessed we are
to have every day to learn to grow to
laugh
to live
to live every day with purpose and
passion to wake up in the morning and be
thankful thankful for that morning
thankful for that opportunity to go into
the world
and live
[Music]
live for them for those that don't have
the opportunity
for those who were stolen away by
death's cruel hand
for them i will live
[Music]
i will revere their memory and i will
live
so let us cry no more
let us mourn no more let us remember
but let us not dwell
instead let us laugh
and love and let us embrace and venerate
everything that life is and every
opportunity
it gives us let us live
for those who live no more
let us live to honor them
and that's what i tried to do
and that's what i'm still trying to do
but i needed that bit of guidance
from myself
and there's even more backstory here
because the book the book was supposed
to come out
october 17 2017. that's when the book
was
being released and and for that release
of the book
i had nine days of media scheduled in
new york city with all the cable news
networks and the syndicated radio
interviews and the articles
and the podcast interviews and all the
stuff was set up and scheduled
so people would hear about the book
and of course all this stuff is what the
publisher and the publicist sets up
because they're trying to sell the book
and it's the big chance to get on the
new york times bestseller list and the
wall street
journal bestseller list and the usa
today list and the amazon list and all
that
and of course i i know that because of
the situation none of this is going to
happen
i know that i have to take care of my
friend i have to see him off and i need
to take care of his mom
and his dad and his brother and his
sister
so the entire nine days of media got
completely canceled
i did zero
didn't even do my own podcast about this
book
in fact that's the only week where this
podcast
did not come out
and i went to three memorial services
for seth
and to his burial at fort rose crans
national cemetery there was a there was
a memorial service in
san diego for the teams
there was one in houston his hometown
for his texas friends and family and
there was one in hawaii which was the
location of the unit
that he was attached to when he died
and i had the honor of
escorting his mom throughout all these
events
as he seth had requested
in a letter he had sent in case he died
and we saw him off as best we could
including going surfing
and including setting something on fire
at
dusk which he had also requested in that
letter
and we burned what was left of an old
surfboard that seth had given to my son
which my
my son had broken
and we also burned an old guitar of mine
that could not be tuned
at least no one could tune it except for
seth somehow he could tune it but no one
else could so it was of no use anymore
so we set them a flame and a giant
bonfire on the beach near our favorite
surf spot
and we push the burning surfboard out to
sea
viking style
then we say goodbye
but we will remember
now what made me think
about all this is that the other day
i got asked a question someone asked me
what's your favorite mantra
and of course when i when i think of
mantras
i think of the generic
and i guess cheesy is the word for lack
of a better word
mantras that you hear the the the if you
can believe it you can achieve it or
or you know failure is part of the road
to success or whatever
whatever those things are the standard
kind of mantras nothing against them but
they're not really
they're not really my thing so this
person asked me what's my favorite
mantra and i say you know i'm not i'm
not really into the whole mantra thing i
don't really
say anything to myself i just i just do
what i do
and this was on a call and and jamie
who is the operations director at
echelon front and she's also an
instructor
and she was on the call as well and she
kind of chimed in to tighten me up with
my answer
she said um she said jocko
she said everything you say is a mantra
you speak in mantras maybe not to
yourself but the rest of us
you speak in mantras and i thought about
that for about a quarter of a second
and i realized that she was absolutely
right
discipline equals freedom yes that's a
mantra
and i absolutely live by that
good that's a mantra stay on the path
that's a mantra
and not only do i say these things but i
actually wrote a book filled with these
mantras
and the title of the book is actually
the mantra itself discipline equals
freedom
and not only that
but i realized
that even though i'm saying oh you don't
need a mantra i need them
at least sometimes
sometimes
like i had when seth died i needed to
hear
or i needed to read my own words to get
me through
to figure out where to go to figure out
what to do
well the the rest of the cool part of
the backstory is that when the book came
out it
it came out with no media at all it
still made all those
lists because you all supported it but i
never covered it on the podcast
and i never explained what it actually
is
what the book is where it came from
and i just released a new version of it
so i figured i'd better tell you
and and what the book is is it's like an
operating system
well i guess it's like my operating
system
and i originally wrote it i originally
wrote it
because people were asking me the same
questions
all the time about the same subject
about jiu-jitsu and about
diet and about workouts and how to
overcome obstacles or how to handle
defeat or
failure or or whatever all the same
questions and so i said you know what
i'm just gonna
my original plan was and i said it on
the podcast and i still get i still get
messages about this what i said on the
podcast is that look you all are asking
me a bunch of these questions i'm just
going to publish a quick ebook
i'll get it together in a few weeks and
get it out there and so
i actually told my publisher hey i'm
going to publish a little ebook about
the stuff on my publisher said no no
please
don't do that do not publish an ebook
he said you just you just were the
number one new york times bestselling
author you don't
publish an ebook
well what i told him was well sorry but
i'm gonna i'm gonna just do this
as an ebook because i don't want you to
tell me
what has to be in there how long it has
to be or what it needs to look like or
any of that stuff
i want to do whatever i want to do and
the only way i can do whatever i want to
do is if i just do it myself
and i was looking into how we were going
to get this thing printed so i i had a
vision in my mind i knew what i wanted
the book to
to be and my publisher to his credit
and and maybe to his own possible
mistake
said i will publish whatever you want
and i said really and he said whatever
you want
so that's what this book is
it's it's not a normal book if you
haven't seen it before it's not a normal
book
the way it's written the the format of
it
the way it's laid out the i guess what
is it the color
of the pages it's just a
different it's a whole different
scenario
of a book and
well i guess if we want to learn a
little bit about the book
there is a visual impact to the book
echo charles is there
yes there is it's and it's really hard
to print
you know because instead of being white
pages with like simple black letters
there's all these
images in the background of every single
page most of the images are
black and then the writing is almost all
in
white so it's it's a different book
has a different visual impact it's cool
some people send me pictures of they'll
just have this book
sitting somewhere
you know just kind of have it in its
position
so so let's go to the book i'll i'll
read through some of the stuff
the the the opening section
is called the way of discipline people
look for the shortcut
the hack and if you came here looking
for that you won't find it
the shortcut is a lie the hack doesn't
get you there
and if you want to take the easy road it
won't take you where you want to be
stronger smarter faster healthier
better free
to reach goals and overcome obstacles
and be the best version of you
possible will not happen by itself
it will not happen cutting corners
taking shortcuts or looking for the easy
way
there is no easy way
there is only hard work late nights
early mornings
practice rehearsal repetition study
sweat
blood toil frustration and
discipline
discipline there must be discipline
discipline the root of all good
qualities
the driver of daily execution the core
principle that overcomes
laziness and lethargy and excuses
discipline defeats the infinite excuses
that say
not today not now i need a rest
i will do it tomorrow
what's the hack how do you become
stronger smarter faster healthier how do
you become better
how do you achieve true freedom there is
only one way
the way of discipline
so that's the opening of the book
you know this is not there's not a bun
this is not a verbose book
you don't get paid by the word
like the old newspaper writers they used
to get paid by the word
i'm not getting paid by the word
trying to say what i'm trying to say
that's it
so so that that is from the first
section of this book and the first
section of this book is called
thoughts and then the second section is
called
actions and the action sections
includes three parts one is fuel
one is one is repair and maintenance
and one is the workouts so
let me give you some more of these
thoughts
[Music]
this one's called overcoming
procrastination
when and where to start
people want to know how to stop laziness
they want to know how to stop
procrastination
they have an idea in their head maybe
even a vision
but they don't know where to start so
they ask and they say where do i start
when is the best time to start and i
have a simple answer here and
now that's it
you want to improve you want to get
better you want to get on a workout
program or a clean diet or start a new
business you want to write a book or
make a movie or build a house or a
computer or an app
where do you start you start right here
when do you start you start right now
you initiate action you go
here is the reality the idea isn't going
to execute itself
that book isn't going to write itself
those weights out in the gym
they aren't going to move themselves you
have to do it
and you have to do it now
so stop thinking about it stop dreaming
about it stop researching
every aspect of it and reading all about
it and debating the pros and cons of it
start doing it
take that first step and make it happen
get after it
here and now
you've been kind of getting after it
lately haven't you yes sir
you made a goal you were telling me you
have goals
is this this is this kind of a new uh
i think it's it was a progressive kind
of thing it started with
kind of certain things you know remember
i told you i got a
not a journal but uh what do you call
like a planner yeah you've got the day
planner yeah and i've tried the planner
thing many times
but not like the one that you actually
write in with a pencil
okay you know the kind like online i got
my digital my phone
you know yeah it's a weird thing there's
a weird thing that happens
when you go physical uh i agree yes for
me that was the case for sure
because some people that's how like if
you go did they got their cool app
organizer app whatever and it works
apparently you know a lot of people use
it so
you know you can't kind of can't refute
that yeah but it didn't work for me
like it didn't stick at all many many
times you know
i even did it on my computer where i was
like oh then i'm gonna and i'm gonna
leave it on the desktop so i can always
see it and
it's still like it worked for certain
things but not for like
not like making a bunch of videos for
this
but it was stuff that i would always
have to revisit mentally you know
and i'd be like okay it's open okay
there it is there it is but no yeah not
for playing so i got
a planner and a pencil a special pencil
for the planner oh
mechanical pencil yep i'm a big
mechanical pencil guy yeah because you
can write
you can write super small you need to
like man yeah it's good
and then you can erase it whatever
anyway so it started with that like
months ago almost a year really
and and that helped it's interesting as
i read this book
you know right now and as i was
reviewing it i was thinking about you
because you've been kind of like almost
involuntarily put on the path i guess
like i mean you've just been overexposed
i mean just
there's no way for you to kind of not i
mean you're sitting here for hundreds
and hundreds of hours
yeah so your life has transformed in
many ways yes
yeah big time it's funny okay here's a
quick story not deviate too much but
i'm gonna so my daughter she's the kind
like
she likes certain things and then
certain things she just straight up
doesn't like so
you make her start running laps hard she
don't like that kind of stuff
so we took her um you know it was it was
my nephew son we took
him to a running coach
and he and this coach has a group of
kids all varying levels
all the way up until like guys getting
full ride scholarships to like
oregon for lacrosse like the like high
level athlete is he a good runner
who the coach no who oh jace
yeah um we don't know that's the thing
we don't know so we
you know and he had some friends in
there and stuff like that so they were
like hey come see this coach and all
this stuff
former marine by the way older guy
and uh and there's a bunch of kids there
and they're all
doing their thing so i'm like yeah let's
throw my daughter in there too she's
seven
but young kid you know and there are a
couple of other young boys in there
eight-ish you know and i'm like she's
not gonna like this if this is hard
conditioning like track practice
which it was by the way um
it's it's she's not gonna like this
stuff she's gonna be whatever and she
did start crying at one point but she
did everything that's the thing okay so
the point is how i
wound up on the path even though i gotta
admit like i've always wanted to like
improve but let's face it i go with the
wave man
and uh and sometimes beneficial some and
a lot of times not for sure but
i watched her and she was nervous she
was not used to this kind of like
intensity you know
and this guy is he the coach he's really
cool man he's
he's but he's not mellow he's making
jokes
he's putting you down all jokes you can
totally tell but you know she didn't
know what to make of that
and so but meanwhile all the kids are
listening so he's like go run now you
know this guy's and the kids are just
going so she has kind of no choice but
to follow the wave
you know if it was me and her by herself
at any given moment she'll be like wait
i don't want to do that i want to do
this yeah but when everyone else is
doing it her whole
at that moment environment is just react
or
moving but you get caught up in that
wave it's kind of interesting because
you you you use the same
metaphor for both
for for two opposite things you said
well you know i want to get better but
you know sometimes i just kind of
go with the wave right exactly and now
all of a sudden you're saying that in
this situation
depending on the direction of the wave
if the wave's going in a good direction
you kind of get caught in that
that's what i feel like you you know you
hanging out with me for the last
five years by the way of just the
podcast because we've been hanging out
for a lot longer than that
and look let's face it you had a lot of
elements of
of discipline and hard work i mean you
you know you played football
obviously you got a hard work do that
you know you were you're awesome at jiu
jitsu
you're uh you know you you obviously
work out hard so you have like
some aspects in your life that were real
kind of strong some other aspects of
your life
we had some areas right we could improve
that maybe just get a little bit
a little bit more on the path they want
to kind of write a different wave
so yeah it's cool yeah that that wave is
powerful like you know how they say
and there's there's a bunch of cool
quote-unquote cool taglines where it's
like oh
your network is your net worth and like
all this and basically they're all sort
of
see that's when somebody asked me like
what's your favorite mantra i started
thinking of all those things and i was
like ah you know what i'm not gonna get
i'm not gonna get here
and jamie was like she tightened me up
she's like hey jocko
everything you say is a mantra i'm like
she's like you might not you might not
think it but we all thinking it's true
it's absolutely true
and the those mantras even the
quote-unquote cheesy ones they all root
they're the rude
they're legitimate yeah they're not
untrue yeah and some of them are
absolutely like yes
100 yeah and these network is your net
network and like show me your five
friends i'll show you
your future or whatever like all that
they're all saying the same thing it's
kind of like your environment
is this big wave that's going to
influence you and you're going to be
riding that thing
and you can fight against it you can
ride with it you can do whatever you
want to do but
bro that's a wave you might want to pick
the right wave if you pick the right
wave you're good but me in this case i
kinda in a way didn't really pick any
wave at all i'm essentially
rode one way right into another wave and
luckily that wave was
going in the right direction and it was
huge it is huge so yeah and i was down
for it so yeah man i'm writing it and
you know trying to do the right things
for sure and
yes very very beneficial check
uh this next section um i'm gonna jump
through a bunch of these real quick but
this one's called
the person you can control
people are not who you want them to be
kill your idols
sure there are things we can learn from
people but people aren't
going to be what you think they are what
they should be
people even those people you have put on
a pedestal are going to be faulted weak
ego maniacal condescending they are
going to be
lazy entitled short-sighted they will be
they will not be perfect far from it
that's fine
learn from their weaknesses of course
learn from their strengths and mimic
and copy them in what they do well but
equally as important learn from their
faults
see what not to do because you can't
control
other people you can't make them what
you want them to be
you can't make them who you want them to
be the only
person you can control is you
so focus on making yourself who you want
to be
faster stronger smarter more humble less
ego
discipline your body free your mind get
up early and go
get after it and you will become the
person you want to be and you
become that person through one small
decision at a time
yeah as you can see this is a book of
mantras
yes and then but it's not all that
it's also there's also some you know
there's actually a bunch of
pragmatic information here's one section
like that
stress first of all and i don't mean to
minimize the stress people face but
imagine what
eugene sledge went through on pelulu and
the tens of thousands of marines
there who suffered unimaginable horror
imagine what david hackworth
imagine david hackworth assaulting enemy
positions in korea
wounded over and over again on the line
still going back for more
imagine the poet warrior alan seeger in
world war one getting ready to go over
the top
and make his rendezvous with death
imagine the thousands of
warriors who have gone before you who
have stood and faced evil and death
and now imagine you
i used to do this myself while in iraq
facing stress
yes we took casualties and yes it was
awful and heartbreaking and every bit as
wretched as i could imagine
but warriors have faced much much worse
the battle of the psalm or gettysburg or
the battle of the bulge or the chosen
reservoir
humans can withstand almost
inconceivable stress
and you can too
so that is your first step gain
perspective and to do that
you must do something critical in many
situations detach
whatever problems or stress you are
experiencing detach from them
stress is generally caused by what you
can't control
the worst thing about incoming artillery
fire is you can't control it
it is happening and you just have to
accept it don't stress about things you
can't control
if the stress is something that you can
control
and you are not that is a lack of
discipline
and a lack of ownership get control of
it impose your will to make it happen
solve the problem relieve the stress if
this stress
is something you can't control
embrace it you can't control it but how
can you look at it from a different
angle
how can you use it to your advantage i
couldn't control the chaos of combat i
had to embrace it i had to figure out a
way to take advantage of it
make it into your ally so don't fight
stress
embrace it turn it on itself use it to
make yourself
sharper and more alert use it to make
you
think and learn and get better and
smarter
and more effective use the stress to
make you
better
this is one this is one that
you know i i kind of have to go over
this one and it's it's
again there's a bunch of these and
they're all very short like this or
within these types of links it's kind of
thing you can read for three minutes
before you start your day before you
uh work out before you go to bed at
night
maybe that might not be the best idea
because if you read you know you might
start getting the
ideas in your head and i have a real
problem with that like i have ideas in
my head
if i have ideas in my head do you have
your do you ever can't sleep does that
ever happen to you
what are you gonna do we're gonna look
at me like that i'm just wondering is
that a thing
it doesn't seem like you'd be like
coming at me with like i have a lot of
trouble sleeping
right it seems like you should fully
embrace sleeping like i might embrace
stress
yes sir uh yeah the answer is yeah yeah
man well for that reason
for sure like if you get a cool idea and
you can't wait like i can't wait to see
uh yeah a cool idea i think that's kind
of cool
about you though is if you get a good
idea at
midnight you can just get up and start
working on it and sleep until 10. yes
sir no factor
me i got like you have
i i'm i think you don't have any
schedule really of any kind
not as far as regular schedules go no
no i don't so other people have
things that they have to do in life on a
daily basis
i understand yeah uh
yeah so so this one um
this is not the kind of things that you
want to read like right before you go to
bed maybe because for me what happens
it's the weirdest thing it's i've never
done a psychedelic
drug before but it kind of feels like a
psychedelic drug where
my mind is going down paths like i'm
thinking about something and i can
feel it like you know what like a
special of like an old school special
effect when you go through some like
space tunnel or like a serious time
tunnel with some wormhole
yeah scenarios right so i'll be doing
that
and i'll and then all of a sudden it'll
go like a roller coaster off to a side
and go down
i'll go down some other what do you call
it go down some other wormhole
of thought but then it just branches off
and it just keeps going so my it's like
i'm going
a thousand miles an hour inside my own
head
and you there's no way i can sleep yeah
i can see how that could be
yeah it's it's a bummer um so i would
say use a little caution if you're gonna
read them before you go to bed
uh i would more read them in the morning
i would more you know
read them during the day have the books
sitting out
have it you know like in a place where
you're thinking about it
and you can pick it up sometimes here's
here's here's one called compromise
when working with other people and
dynamic situations and relationships and
deals
a person especially a leader must
compromise finding the common ground
between teams merging different
approaches to the same problem bridging
personalities
with people who might not get along
reaching agreements and courses of
action
all these require compromise and in many
cases a failure to compromise is a
failure to succeed
so so it's important because you know a
lot of times people might
well not even might a lot of times
people have the impression there's no
compromise
when the reality is like oh what do you
want to do that sounds like a good idea
let's move in that direction
as a leader it's you you actually have
to do that
a good leader does that a good leader
compromises
to a lot of things right of course
you're gonna have principles and values
that you
can't compromise but those should be
small well not small
they're huge but they should be a small
number of things
so going back to the book but those are
external compromises with
other people other humans that have
their own personalities and ethos and
issues and compromise is needed in order
to unify
so to work with them compromise is a
must but internally
it's different with myself i have to
hold the line
there are areas within myself where i
cannot
compromise i am going to work hard i am
going to train hard
i am going to improve myself i am going
i am not going to rest on my laurels i'm
going to own my mistakes and confront
them
i am going to face my demons i am not
going to give up
or give out or give in i am going to
stand
i am going to maintain my
self-discipline and on those points
there will be no compromise not now
not ever
so reading that right before i go to
sleep probably not going to do it
because then i'd probably be doing
burpees in the corner of the room but
um a ton a ton of these things uh
you know i'm going to skip through a
bunch of them right now
there's one that i like in here it's
called binary code
i know you like that because you're a
computer expert oh yeah sure
extra hell yeah jade jade likes this
jade likes this yeah
it says machines make their decisions
based on binary code
yes or no it is not complicated
are you going to work out yes or no are
you going to get up yes or no
are you going to get off the couch yes
or no are you going to eat that donut
yes or no this is not complicated
and sometimes you have to put yourself
into this mode
binary decision making
are you going to be weak or strong are
you going to be healthy or unhealthy
are you going to improve your life are
you going to make it worse
are you going to sacrifice long-term
success for sure
short-term gratification
you know the right answers you know the
right decisions
don't over complicate
binary decision making make the right
decisions
that's your whole deal right it's kind
of it's kind of my big part
and it's more about yourself though i
think like with other people that's the
thing that's the thing that's so strange
about this is
this stuff rings so true in my head for
me but
like with other people as a leader
interacting
in relationships like you this doesn't
work yeah
it's weird but yeah when you when it
comes to stuff that like you're taught
and to be honest like
like with me like even just like the
look you know like if all you know
i tend to from time to time or whatever
go down certain
over explanations and like all this
stuff or whatever and you're looking at
me with a zero
like a straight up zero almost like it's
it's literally zero what's a zero you
know you got the one and you got the
zero all right
that's the positive value negative i'm
assuming yeah got it got it
um and the value of your statement is
zero i got it
you're literally looking at me like that
kind of like oh yeah and here's the
thing though
that's real beneficial too though and
that's part of this whole wave i think
anyway
where you know i'm over here you know
we're all in our own head from time to
time if not all the time or whatever and
then it's good to have that little
reflective
like situation where i'm saying what's
in my head to see how it sort of lands
on the outside world
and when that thing is literally like
not computing at all you're like all
right well i guess i can do away with
that thought you know kind of thing
and then you know sometimes you'll have
like a reaction that's okay that's maybe
viable whatever and
after a while all those zeros and ones
sort of kind of
formulate a little little line of code
you know and then we can go do some
things you know kind of thing
and and that's kind of like the
influence but it's interesting how that
you put it in that book where you got to
get in that mode because you can't be
like that with everything you know
but sometimes you just get in that mode
and you're like all right like
especially with the workouts i mean
that's an obvious one
where you're like right you're going to
work out or not and if you're like later
oh okay so no then are you gonna work
out right now because that's what the
plan was or that's what you were
trying to do or whatever right and then
if you're like
oh i'm not it's like oh it's real clear
you know
so yeah man if you can get in that mode
when you need to either yes or no
and you know that's the thing i think to
to
complement what you're saying when
when you take all that gray area out
yeah you know
this is the important thing when you
take the gray area out you know what the
right answer is
right you can make a lot of things that
make it seem like there's a whole bunch
of different options in it but there's
really only
two options you're either going to work
out or you're not yeah and all these
other little things that you're thinking
they're they're not they're just they're
just they're just
junk yeah right they're just jumped yeah
that gray area as you mentioned it's
like there's so much
danger in there there's so much oil and
slippery stuff in there
leave that leave that out man so like
okay the workout right
well it's a big gray area you can throw
in there i'll do it later
that's one right because the fact is you
can do it later and get it done
straight up kind of you know you got
something super important like that's a
possibility
you know but you start throwing that
that in there it's like oh man
that becomes dangerous because i would
say if if
considering that i'm a normal person if
i throw in the idea of i'll do it later
the chance of me doing it later goes
down way more if
compared to if i just say hey did it am
i going to do it now or am i not going
to do it am i going to do it or not i'm
going to do it
so explain that to me so if you say if
you had three choices
do it now do it later don't do it
the easiest pick is kind of do it later
right but do it later it doesn't lead to
execution
it doesn't leave yeah direct it doesn't
directly lead to execution
what's your percentage of when you say
you'll do it later what's the percentage
of execution later
well now we're going deeper because do
it later what does that actually mean
how later in an hour later let's say
tomorrow
in a in a window of time
that could still be considered part of
this scenario yeah yes i do
i would say a maximum uh so my later we
got to establish that
later as opposed to tomorrow because
that's yeah you missed the workout later
is definitely
i mean same day in this scenario for a
workout we're definitely talking about
today
same day right um yeah that's usually
like a three four five
six hour window so if i can so the
percentage of me doing it later it's
weird because you know maps kind of form
in your mind so
if i don't get it done in the morning
like before noon
because you want to get your lunch or
what yeah wait do you do you work out on
an empty stomach
yeah so yeah me too the norm is
i don't eat nothing until the workout
dinner time okay dinner and then late
dinner that's sort of it
wait did you say dinner and late dinner
so two dinners yeah
i didn't you know what the [ __ ] never
shared this with me bro yeah and then
the pre-go to bed dinner
that's interesting interesting um but
the window how the window goes and it's
just a schedule that established itself
in my mind
is a workout during the day or during
the morning if i don't do that it's a 4
30 workout
pretty much 4 30 across the board that's
cool so you put a little deadline on
yourself
kind of kind of that kind of becomes
binary right it's either now or it's at
4 30. yeah
yeah that's kind of a good good program
yeah what happens at 4 30.
i i work so so you're saying get it done
later actually you do
a good percentage of getting it done
later yeah but that's going to make a
really good point because technically i
did go binary
in almost like a second level binary
situation which
starts to become less and less binary
either now or 4 30.
yeah it's like for me 4 30 means a
different it means 12 hours prior
4 30 in the morning but yeah man but
again if and i do this naturally
and it's good to have these kinds like
this book or whatever just sort of point
it out for you
where if i don't get it if i'm not
prepping
the workout drinking water out there
shoes on blah blah blah
if i'm if that's not happening between
four and four thirty
if i get to 4 45 5 if it's past five it
probably won't happen
just because there's other things that
the household kind of needs me for you
know
it's it's so cool that your mind
can be so easily reset like you're like
oh you've got this book like
if you pick this book up and you're
reading it
you're going to get it done right i mean
you're
it's going to hit you it's going to hit
you
you're going to think yourself you know
what that's correct i need to go do this
i need to control myself i need to make
this happen i need to go and execute i
need to
i need to go into binary mode and make
this happen like
you have so much influence over your
brain that's so
good if you put your brain on the right
wave
because if you put it on the right wave
you're going to go places if you put in
the wrong wave we're going down
down the wrong place man we're going in
a bad way
so you're and it's incredible that you
can so easily
put your well here's the difference you
can put your it takes a small bit of
effort you pick the book
this book you read it right you're like
going to go get something
that took a small amount of effort very
small amount of effort and it puts you
on the right path
what's strange is if you don't do
anything
we know where it goes right it just kind
of the other wave is just kind of there
just always just pulling at you just
dragging you down oh
it's just constantly there yeah i mean
the wave analogy is really
good really spot on because like if
you're in the ocean
right you're going this way you're going
that way you're going there
so every once in a while you catch a
current you know go
you know kind of in this direction for a
significant amount of time or whatever
or distance and then but by if you get
on one of those waves bro you're going
full speed
you know what two you can get caught in
a rip current that's pulling it out
like in a bad way right you go down the
downward spiral of
horribleness addiction and savagery
right wrong way yep it's true um but
i've always looked at this book
as like i mean it seems like a field
like a for real manual you know how like
okay it's called a field mirror exactly
right
so you know how like if if your car has
a i don't know
check engine light or you know whatever
some issue with your car and you're not
you know super well versed in like auto
mechanics whatever
and you're like hey man i better look
into this i got a small issue with my
car i got to know how to solve this
issue where do you go
the freaking owner's manual or a
mechanic but whatever let's say
if you needed some answers you go to the
manual
you know that manual is for your car
straight up you can go on the internet
for sure but you go to the manual you're
going to get the answer for your
question or whatever it's directed
directly linked to your issue with your
specific card
this manual if you regard that as your
manual
for not necessarily your physical but
but for how you
are gonna be those answers
are for you then oh yeah
all day because you know it's easy to go
on the internet
the gram right i'm gonna follow an
inspirational person
you know and maybe that applies to me
maybe it doesn't and then after a while
it's all just sort of like yeah i heard
that before
cool saying let me go back to what i was
doing kind of a thing
and it sort of doesn't land anymore but
if you regard again like this book
for you like you need and you say you
know just how you said a second ago
where you can just just pick it up and
just read part of it you know
for a minute or whatever that that
answer whatever you read that is for you
isn't it crazy though that like and
that's what that's what
one of the reasons why i wanted to talk
about this is because like that whole
thing with seth like i
needed my own book i needed to go to the
owner's manual
yeah i needed that myself i wrote these
words
i contemplated them i lived through them
i
garnered the experience and then at the
moment
in time i actually needed to go to this
manual and say what am i supposed to do
right now
um yeah yeah exactly right and that
there's all kinds of
i mean that's an extreme example but you
know even as i read like the binary code
thing it's like yes
oh yeah how easy is it to just go in
that other wave over there that's kind
of going to a
horrible you know lame weak place filled
with
gray excuses and justifications if
you're good at justifying yourself yeah
gray all day you know not black and
white anymore
so that's that's what the that's what
the thoughts
and there's a there's a bunch of these
more and this the the
the new field manual that's the
differences i added up a bunch more
of into this thought section about mind
control about weakness and about
destroyer mode and about the application
of discipline
about the fear of failure and about what
to do when you're not feeling it and
what
what to do when you get overwhelmed and
how to detach and how to handle defeat
and
just all these things that we need help
with that i need help with that we
as human beings need help with
a bunch of stuff in there that you can
pick up and that will keep you on the
path
but as we know thoughts only go so far
right we have to take action which is
the next section of the book it is
called
actions and and the first little section
in actions is physical training
subtitle getting after it yes sir
physical training back to the book there
are all kinds of benefits from physical
training you will be healthier
this is a fact by working out you will
increase your endorphins testosterone
growth hormones cardiac valium
insulin sensitivity and natural killer
cells
those changes will help prevent or treat
the following health issues high blood
pressure obesity heart disease type 2
diabetes
insomnia and depression boom
still not convinced working out will
make you smarter
yes smarter it improves blood flow to
the brain it boosts
growth hormones that promote growth of
new nerve cells
it improves synaptic plasticity
the ability for neurons to send and
receive messages
it releases brain chemicals that help
cognition
like dopamine glutamate norenephrine
and serotonin it also boosts the
production of brain derived
neurotropic factor a protein that helps
with mental processes
but don't just take my word for it go
do get some exercise done and pay
attention to your mental state
you will feel more aware sharper and
smarter this is real
there you go this is like oh why do you
want to physically why didn't why do you
want to work out it
actually makes you smarter look it makes
you stronger
it makes you more healthy but it may my
daughter
my oldest daughter was taking a taking a
what a final exam
finals week all day and she's all
stressed out you know
because she likes to get whatever high
grades and stuff
yeah that whole thing yeah and uh she
was like i go
you need to go and and it just so
happened when i see this i was reviewing
for this book
but i was reviewing like you know i did
a bunch of research and read a bunch of
stuff
because look i know i feel i know i feel
smarter and better when i work out
but when i was writing this book i said
okay what is that
you know so i started asking i talked to
peter at tier 2.
i was like hey what what is up with this
and these are the kind of things these
big words these big medical words that i
put in there
right sure so i told my daughter i said
go for like
at least a 20-minute workout before this
examination
yeah and and she did and i was like okay
cool so
get that's what you need that's why
we're working out that's why we're
working out it's so
obvious that it's so good for you and
even from the earliest of podcasts echo
charles
you made this statement exercise is like
the thing that you can do in your life
that will positively impact the most
other things in your life yes sir which
is a bold statement and a true statement
in my humble opinion
stress the good and the bad this is this
is an area where i talk about stress
and look in order to improve we need
stress
we need to push the body and the mind in
order to get better
one of our main physical reactions to
stress is to resist release the hormone
cortisol into the body it has a
multitude of effects including making
glucose available to brain so
i go into this what it does what stress
does to you
and and it's positive because it it
generates energy it focuses energy
it focuses you on immediate threats it
prepares you for immediate threats
so that stuff is all good it allows you
to do better in the world
but you can also go overboard with it
stress can be bad so i go through that
too much stress and the cortisol is
released too often
it it it's like a car running in the red
so i go into that whole thing so what we
have to do is you have to stress the
body and the mind in order to improve
but obviously you can't over stress it
so i talk through that whole thing
and here's something i was like oh you
know i'll cover this on the podcast this
section is called sleep
cool this is for the haters can i use
that word
and not be a 15 year old girl well yeah
yeah sure
the haters so
so obviously you know i get up early
every day
and get stuff done
oh man you took it back down the other
day what up oh yeah
what happened oh yeah i was traveling so
good point so the other day
i was traveling my flight
was delayed or whatever and i didn't get
back into
sd until midnight got home
at 12 30 and i had spent a couple days
on east coast
time so i wasn't even really like i
wasn't tired so
i probably fell asleep at like 1 30. my
alarm went off at 4 30 and i was like
i'm gonna play this
see what this feels like at 4 30. at 4
30 yeah
so i went back to sleep why because
sleep is good for you
yes sir and if you don't have enough
sleep you don't
you don't perform well you don't think
well now listen
here's the thing people go crazy with
this right yeah
and and people you should read this you
should like they say oh if you have less
than eight hours of sleep you're like
being a drunk yeah
that is just factually untrue right i'm
telling you i
have like you've been to the muster
right
at some of the early musters where life
and i are on stage
we're answering questions we're
interacting with people we're role
playing we're going through dynamic
scenarios
we're we're performing cognitive high
level
cognitive tasks for eight and a half
straight eight and a half nine
ten hours straight we had one hour of
sleep like not kidding there's some of
those monsters the new york mustard i
think
we had like one hour of sleep yeah so
to if we had if if before the muster
i had done 16 shots of jagermeister
the buster would have been a lot
different now some people might have
liked it but most people would have
wanted their money back
so look sleep so so this people think i
don't like sleep or i don't support
sleep or i think
you know and it's not true and and i
would say when people oh you think
you're
you're giving people advice that's
unhealthy here's the actual advice that
i give people
from the book sleep is a necessity
humans need sleep failure to get enough
sleep has serious side effects
lack of sleep can cause negative
hormonal changes interfere with the
metabolizing glucose of glucose increase
blood pressure and suppress the immune
system less sleep
also means less human growth hormone in
your body
which means less muscle mass and weaker
bones
mentally the brain is impacted as the
ability to pay attention and concentrate
begins to diminish and problem solving
and basic reasoning becomes less acute
furthermore
over an extended period there are
psychological effects
like paranoia and even hallucinations
so that's me talking about sleep you
need to sleep
i'm not anti-sleep
isn't there a thing called a fast
sleeper
we'll get there we'll get there so so
check this out
but how much sleep is enough different
people need different amounts of sleep
newborns can sleep up to 17 hours a day
toddlers can sleep 12 hours a day as
people grow older
less sleep is required teens generally
need 8 to 10 hours
and by the time people are full of
adults eight hours becomes the standard
even though the actual number is between
seven and nine hours depending on the
individual
some people genetically need even less
sleep than that but those people are
rare
i'm one of those people and this isn't i
don't have the proof
well here's my proof
it's not improved my oldest daughter is
like me
like last night she was studying she
went to bed at midnight
i woke up at 4 30 she's up and then she
took an exam cognitive not impaired
right
she's going to get an a sure you know
what i'm saying
so but but my second daughter
that girl likes to sleep like she'll get
out of bed when you go drag her out of
bed right like she likes to sleep
my son kind of it's kind of normal i
would say
my wife she digs that sleep so
some of my kids get some of it my
youngest daughter she's sort of
a little bit i would she likes that
sleep too
but but so there is so so i think there
is
some sort of genetic thing
um here's
but it's it's people also go look
it's so rare there's no chance you have
it okay cool i'm only i can only tell
you
people like people say sleep more i i
i'm not
trying to sleep less i'm more than happy
to sleep you know
but it just doesn't happen
uh so going on here but it isn't only
genetics you can also sleep less and
fall asleep faster if you are in good
physical condition eating clean and have
a clear mind
for me the better condition i'm in and
the cleaner i eat the more
quickly i will fall asleep and the less
sleep i need do you notice this
do you notice that you need less sleep
when you're fasting oh
i i don't notice but i'm not paying
attention to it okay
i like when i'm when i'm fasting i'm i
feel like i'm on
fire yeah and i
i just did a fast i just did a 48 hour
and i feel
i felt like again like i was waking up
earlier than i'd normally wake up
so while i do have short sleep genetics
on my side
equally important is that i stay healthy
and eat clean
what about when you eat junk how don't
you need to sleep more
oh yeah but actually you know what it's
real inconsistent when you eat junk or
sorry when i eat junk
it's sometimes i'll sleep less but
be wanting to sleep more but you know
the kind like you're tired and you feel
sleepy but you can't like go
to sleep you know it's like that there's
a lot of that that's the worst thing oh
yeah
i agree you feel like you wish you would
sleep more but you can't you kind of
can't
just get up yeah exactly and feel like
crap or whatever and
sort it you know maybe catch the next
wave of sleepiness i guess
the and on the inverse when you're
talking about like when you
exercise consistent you eat clean or
whatever and it's really different where
and it's really
real clear where you feel freaking solid
during the day and then once that
bedtime ish kind of rolls around you
just feel the wave just crashing yeah
and you're like oh
it's it's sleep time so straight up so
good
yeah it's real when you worked out hard
you had a good day you ate clean
you get to the end of the day you're
like boom you're out bro that's how i
was yesterday and i
and i got like an hour less sleep than i
normally did the day before
so but i got up solid boom eating good
now that we're thinking about this when
i have like those weird rollercoaster
brain rides
that's usually that's usually when i'm
like something's
messed up you know whether i'm eating
crap or
or whatever yeah
bro i was the kind like i do quizzes
and story time from with the kids before
bed every night this is like what eight
o'clock 8 30.
bro is the time like it's kind of in the
middle
of a question that i'm asking it's you
falling
asleep straight up that's a good day
right there yeah i was like okay it's
about that time you know
yeah i i've i've had that where when my
kids were little and i was still in the
damns
and you know you're just getting up at 4
30 you're doing whatever you're doing at
work come home
you know and you're just get in bed read
that story next thing you know it's
three o'clock in the morning four
o'clock in the morning what just
happened
my wife left me in there because she was
running around with three kids at the
time you know trying to
get them all squared away she like oh
you got the kid
school she probably went to a bar i
don't know what she thought she
knows that girl went to sleep she used
to fall asleep with some one kid
almost every night it was crazy uh so
going on here
and finally i choose not to sleep in i
don't give into the pillow
i don't give in to the temptation of
warm blankets or soft pillow
i mobilize the will to get me out of bed
and get into the game
obviously i'm an advocate of waking up
early but since sleep must be a priority
to maintain health how can we get enough
sleep
and still wake up early the answer is
simple go to bed earlier
go to bed earlier now
i'm going to skip a little bit here go
forward well this
i talk about some of the benefits like
what are the benefits why do i wake up
early
and i mean first there's some simple
math but why do you wake up early the
world's is yours
when you're up before the enemy there's
no traffic the gym is empty there's no
one to distract you
or call you or send you some stupid text
about something you don't care about
so there's like there's all these
benefits to to being up early
but then going back to the other point
falling asleep
how do you fall asleep so this is kind
of what we were just talking about
number one and there's a whole section
i'm going to read some highlights of it
number one get tired
yes get tired if you are not active
throughout the day you won't be tired
you know what's weird is recording the
podcast depending on the podcast
i'm usually super wired when we get done
recording
and then i'm tired you know it's a
mental it's a mental work
yeah fully number two turn off the
computer
turn off the smartphone stop checking
social media and stop
watching one more youtube video
sure there's some science that says that
the light from the computer
and phone screen tricks your mind into
thinking there's daylight and time to
get up
but on top of that the internet is
filled with professionals that create
content with the sole purpose of getting
you to click on it yes
clickbait is real and just like the bait
used in fishing it is a trick
to get you hooked so don't don't click
it you will get nothing positive at all
number three read if your mind is still
active when you reach your bedtime
that's okay
get into bed and get a book and start
reading reading is relaxing it settles
your mind and makes you smarter so do it
dude reading will reading
i think reading is a massive sleep aid
yeah
yeah every once in a while i like you
not every once well most of them
actually in my experience because i
wouldn't be reading a boring book
unless it's for a specific purpose but
usually they're interesting books
so at first i might be like oh kind of
excited but yeah man
after and it depends on the day or
whatever but it can be like after like
10 minutes 15 minutes
i you know the kind of books i read
because i read them on the podcast all
the time i'm talking about books about
war and combat in the most
dynamic heroic situations like even
those books
if i'm reading i'll be like oh if it's
night time and i'm reading i'll i will
get tired off all sleep
yeah i mean i won't i don't fall asleep
while i'm reading i rarely do that but
i'll be like okay i'm tired yeah i'm
gonna shut the book and go to bed oh
yeah and that's exactly what i'm saying
or maybe at first
if it's like super interesting or
exciting or whatever book
you're like at first you're like oh man
let's get some reading
going you know about this whatever
you're reading about and then yeah after
like i said it depends on how your state
of mind is but
as far as time goes but yeah after a
little while right you're ready you're
ready to go sleep
i just got done reading a book for the
podcast that it was
it was a book that i like was actively
couldn't sleep because i just was like
i'm going to read
more of this because i want to know
what's about to happen it's freaking
crazy
number four most important the key to
getting to sleep early
is getting up early no it might not help
you tonight but
tomorrow night it will if you need seven
full hours of sleep and you want to get
up at 4 30 a.m that means you
need to go to bed at 9 30 p.m but it is
hard to
force yourself to sleep at 9 30. so you
stay up until 11 30.
you should still get up at 4 30. yes
that will only be five hours of sleep
and yes you will likely feel tired
throughout the day
which is actually good because at the
end of the day you want to be tired
now you can go to bed at 9 30 and get
yourself back on track
yeah that's that's the part that people
if you want to be tired at night at 9 30
you need to get up early you can't you
can't get up at
nine in the morning and expect to be
tired
at nine at night it won't happen yeah
and the last thing is do it every day
right and this is like you know
weekends whatever just do the same time
look if you want to give yourself an
extra half an hour i don't even
recommend that i recommend you get up at
the same time every day
yeah that um
here's a mistake i think that well when
i say some people
me i make this mistake or i have made
this mistake straight up where i'll be
like okay yeah i'm going to do that i
want to get up early you know
earlier whatever so i'll just wake up
earlier and be tired throughout the day
but what i did is i didn't look at the
big picture i was like i'll just
automatically be tired at night you know
but
what i did was i would laze through the
day skip workout
a lot of laying down on the couch you
know a lot more than normal
and then you know basically since you're
tired
you kind of adjust your activity
accordingly you know in a bad way
so you do just way less and then
nighttime comes you're not as tired as
as you could have been if you just went
about your normal routine
sure you gotta power through it a little
bit harder for sure if you're on less
sleep or whatever but at the end when it
comes
time to sleep which was your goal it's
gonna
be way more like it's going to happen
way easier you know
or it's going to happen in my case just
straight up doesn't happen i'm freaking
out late again
can't go sleep whatever yep got to be
careful so yeah do the normal routine
don't be slacking i got a little section
on here on power naps people like do you
take naps
yes i do if i'm super tired but i and i
explain the whole thing in here elevate
your feet above your heart which i
learned from one of my high school
teachers
and then i only sleep for like eight
minutes yeah
and if you're really tired eight minutes
seems like you just got a full
on massive amount of sleep
yeah remember we were talking about the
two types of tired
there's that oh yeah yeah there's sleepy
tired and then there's like
physical fatigue yeah and then you know
what it kind of
in the whole eight-minute nap thing
sometimes six minutes
it's almost like and this is all what do
you call hypothesis
we'll say that where if like
if you could just like if you just did
like a
marathon freaking podcast or you know
after you do a podcast you mentioned
where you're kind of tired you know
something that that that required
like cognitive effort for a
somewhat sustained amount of time you
you're not exhausted physically but
mentally you might have like
this sharpness that you usually have is
just dull because like you're
you're like it's almost like a
superficial
conscious like cognitive like a bit
almost that's what it almost seems like
so
if i'm working on something on the
computer like admin
numbers or freaking stuff not editing
stuff like
you know work for like three hours
and then it's workout time i'm gonna
take one of those six minutes eight
minutes and it helps so
much yep for sure but the thing is like
six minutes eight minutes what can what
can possibly recover in that i don't
know
it's something it's real oh yeah it's
real and it's like you ever have a dream
in eight minutes oh yeah oh yeah
full-on dreams you ever have those
little half dreams
like okay so usually it happens does
your body move yes but it's something
very specific though where
sometimes you just like feel like oh you
just jump ran almost like oh no for me
it's cause someone's swinging a battle
axe in my head that makes sense
but yes it was it's that though it's
something specific where like
like did the other day i was i was
getting one in and
my son in my little dream it lasted
literally like two seconds
it's like a two second dream almost and
my son like ran under my legs
and i like had to jump over them okay in
my dream yeah so i jumped and i was like
that's what caused me to jump but it was
i remember it was my son ran
under my legs that sounds a lot more
pleasant than a battle axe yeah a
barbarian with a battle axe yeah minor
kill you
probably a lot different than yours for
sure uh
next section the workouts
everyone wants to know what should a
workout actually consist of
and first of all let me say this the
most important thing is to do
something anything walk jog calisthenics
swim lift some weights hike stretch do
burpees
play a game of basketball or go get on
the jiu-jitsu map some people aren't
sure what to do for a workout
but that is often just an excuse
exercise doesn't need to be some complex
multi-level multi-dimensionally
multi-dimensional scientifically proven
methodology
but it does need to be something so
go through a whole section about the
workouts and then i actually
put workouts in the book
to see the actual workouts go to
appendix the workouts again use the
workouts as a guide
learn about your own body push yourself
most important be consistent and
consistency starts with
getting in the gym if you are tired or
sore or burned out
don't just give up completely go to the
gym and stretch move
do some light exercises but keep the
routine routine in place
too often people take the day off and
that turns into two
and two into three and then they've gone
a week without getting in a good workout
so
maintain the routine maintain the
discipline
i didn't i didn't cover this section but
that's i've had a lot of people
like this attitude you're tired you're
sore you feel like you need a day off
cool do it tomorrow still do the workout
today do tomorrow because it's
it's tomorrow's then take the day off
tomorrow take the day off tomorrow yeah
yep take the day off tomorrow so
you know you go into that spot you're
like you know what i could probably just
you know i've worked out really hard
it's been it's been six days
it's been three days straight i'm kind
of tired i'm kind of sore
i do have this you know project due
i should really take the day off today
okay cool you can take the day off
tomorrow
you still have to do it today and guess
what you wake up tomorrow you don't need
to take a day off it was
all just negotiating but the cool thing
is you maybe you do need a day off
cool you wake up the next day and you're
like god i am so cool take the day off
yeah
yeah and that's a pretty and i've done
that before where i'm be honest i'm not
that good at doing that
yet but i've done that before where i'll
be like no i'm going to power through in
fact i'm going to go as hard as i
freaking can i'm going to go extra hard
and then i'll take it tomorrow
and then on on times where i really did
need the day off the next day i feel
even worse like oh yeah way more
obviously
yeah but other times it's most of the
time exactly what you say it's just the
day
you don't feel like it you freaking
whatever you did last night or whatever
it's some
some other factor that has to do with
just the day you know the circumstances
you can also uh just like have some
minimum workout that you must do
yeah yeah i have that well like oh you
know what oh you're gonna be
you're you're you're you're a millimeter
from not doing anything
okay i'm gonna go do the minimum workout
i'm gonna do this just this stuff
get it done and then if i still feel
like crap tomorrow i'll i'll take a
legit day off
yeah and another thing that that is
almost like a thing that gets revealed
is that minimum workout thing has
obviously a bunch of benefits but
usually you know how like and it again
depends on what you were doing before
the workout maybe what you're doing last
night whatever
but a lot of times once you just get the
blood flowing
right or once yeah yeah and this is the
thing i don't know the the full ins and
outs of it you gotta ask the
actual fitness person but like it's it's
called priming priming your body and
mind whatever for workout
so a lot of times you're just de-primed
i'm
i made that word up d prime but you
understand what i'm saying right it's
the opposite of falling
sometimes during you're just more d
prime than you normally are
you know and you're just really not into
it for other reasons you know
so sometimes that minimum workout you're
like all right and you sort of
inadvertently prime your whole
deal yeah and you're like oh wait i'm
not sore and tired and over training
yourself
i noticed that a lot with uh with with
any body part
but like your legs for sure you know
when it's squat day
yeah now we don't know what what unseen
mechanisms are at work in your brain
that are telling you that you're like
more sore but a lot of times you're
rolling into
squat day and you're feeling in your
mind you're thinking i'm pretty sore
you're really negotiating hard for that
day off
yeah and you really notice after you and
even your first couple sets
you know you just do you just do some
some bodyweight squats just to warm up
and you're like oh i'm definitely sore
then you do the bar then you do the 45
pound bar just you're just getting
warmed up yeah
you take the pvc pipe you do some
overhead squats
you're like whoa i'm definitely sore and
then when you start putting some
some weight on you start realizing i'm
actually not sorry oh you start feeling
good and you're you're good to go
yeah you were good to go that's what
that's that's
that happens a lot yeah that happens a
lot
it seems to happen a lot on on the good
old squad day too
so when you say and this is more your
personal thing
uh well like your squat day or whatever
will you do just squats or legs or
whatever
or is it like a you know yeah i mean i
do some other stuff but yes i will be
other body parts or other exercises for
legs no really it's just bot just just
squat
day yeah squat day which encompasses all
kinds of different
leg work we'll say yeah i've done i've
always done multiple body parts
but usually squat day would would be
just
part of a just a multiple body part day
but when i saw it it was a hack
kind of out of laziness in a way where
i'd be like you know what i'm just going
to designate one day for just
squats and then i started incorporating
just a small muscle group like a curls
situation maybe some triceps then do the
squats something that's not going to
exist
so if if i do like shoulders for example
depends on the workout obviously but if
i'm going like hardcore shoulder press
then freaking super set of this and that
you know a whole
shoulder workout and you want me to go
do squats now
after the age of about 30
that started to be less and less of a
sustainable thing mentally
in my mind okay that's interesting so
you've gotten mentally weaker if you've
got as you've gotten older yes sir i
have
apparently that's strange you sure you
just didn't get it smarter where you
realized if you really wanted to push
you needed to focus you need to
prioritize and execute
i would say that that's a good way of
putting and making it sound better oh
rationalizing right and maybe
rationalize it or maybe that was the
case the whole time
you know where i could be benefiting way
more from these
this this leg workout if i just
soloed it one day rather than doing a
big
other body part workout then then the
legs and vice versa too because
sometimes i would do the squats first
and then suffer through a shoulder
workout or something like this yeah
but now anyway that's what i do it's
weird too like i always
i always if possible lift before
jiu jitsu yeah right that's do you do
that yeah 100 and i'll tell you
it's it's not because
it's it's not it's it's it's because
jiu jitsu i don't want to go and work
out
i would rather go to jiu jitsu with some
muscle fatigue
then go to work out with muscle fatigue
yeah
even though isn't that that seems
backwards that seems counterintuitive
i never think well i'm gonna compete
against echo so i want to be ready to go
yeah so that seems like the intuitive
thing but i would much rather
just be a little bit tired when i'm
rolling with whoever
than to be all than to be tired when i
roll into the gym
yeah well no i think if you know the
dynamics of both types of workouts i
think it's
it's obvious that you do want to lift do
a lifting before jiu jitsu because
jiu-jitsu has quick diminishing returns
with strength yeah true very quick
endurance not so much but
muscle like strength or whatever um
it's quick but it's the opposite for
lifting weights
so you need your strength you don't
necessarily need that much endurance
depending on the workout obviously but
as far as lifting weights goes you don't
need that much endurance
but um when you go to jiu-jitsu if you
don't have that much strength but as
long as you can kind of sustain and you
know do this thing i mean you're not
going to run like
a whole crossfit games routine and then
go to jiu jitsu and think you're going
to feel good i mean it's a little bit
different you know but
that's true although i'll tell you like
i'll do some crazy workouts and still go
to
barely remember that i mean and i'm not
talking i go
like walk from one to the other you know
i work out in the morning really hard
and then
in the afternoon i'm going to jiu jitsu
yeah by that time you get what 80 90
of your strength so it's not that big of
a deal yeah and jiu-jitsu is different
like that because
your energy output in jiu-jitsu is it's
variable very much so and you can
modulate
fully like and you know it's gonna
obviously depend on who you're rolling
with as well you go with a tornado dude
who's good it's like right you're going
to feel that workout in the morning
if you have that kind of day but a
normal day of jujitsu where some guys
you go hard sometimes you go medium
sometimes you don't have to go as hard
as
as far as that goes you can modulate and
yeah navigate through the energy
output easy but as far as like the type
of
exercise versus the other type of
exercise lifting whatever
if you switch them around you do jiu
jitsu first and all that sort of
sustained output
and you think you're gonna go into a
lifting and freaking push hard
yeah that's a weird thing man it's a
weird thing but that's
it seems to be you and i are in
agreement on that uh
got a section in here on building a home
gym and this is
obviously with uh the world that we're
in right now with covid
this is a very good thing to have a home
gym and you can
i go through all the all the kinds of
different things that you should get
first and
the considerations you know getting a
pull-up bar
and and a lot of things like you know
you i don't have enough money i mean you
can get a pull-up bar for nine dollars
at home depot i'm not even talking about
you know you go
whatever you can get a piece of pipe you
have a pull-up bar you can get a set of
rings for pretty cheap like there's
there's ways that you can make it happen
so i got a little section in there i'm
building a home gym
yeah the home gym thing that the i think
the primary factor that you really have
to kind of
consider and navigate is the space yeah
more so than the money
because money is like for the most part
you can like
spend way less or just you know
make payments or all or whatever even
the space though you see people that do
really
cool creative things to get good
workouts in a small space
yeah you do and you you really need very
minimal
equipment to be in awesome shape really
the only piece of equipment that i think
you
actually need is a pull-up bar because
if you have a pull-up bar
you can do pull-ups but you can auto you
can already do push-ups
not dips but push-ups you can do all
kinds of chest variation push-up very
like you can get crazy with push-ups
there's millions of different varieties
of push-ups you can do you can do squats
you can do lunges
you can do you can do basically your
whole body can do handstand push-ups for
your shoulders like there's so many
things that you can do
if you just have a pull-up bar if you
don't have a pull bar you're kind of
yeah that's true yeah like does it you
can't just like because all those things
that you said aside from the the
anything pulling or whatever you you
don't need anything you just need the
ground you just need the ground
yeah man maybe a wall a wall or a tree
or whatever
almost every building has a wall yes and
every yeah or a tree
or something thing outside or whatever
you know but
yeah the pulling thing it's hard to
start to access
if you don't have like a pull-up bar
rings are
really good because then you can not
only do pull-ups but you can also do
dips and then there's all kinds of other
crazy things that you can do with rings
so rings are also awesome uh the next
section is called
martial arts again this is an operating
this is my operating system and part of
my operating system as you just heard us
talking about is martial arts
and i say everyone should train in
martial arts just as everyone should eat
but just as food is different and varies
greatly in how it affects your body not
all martial arts are created equal
there are three broad forms of martial
arts
grappling striking and weapons grappling
uses
leverage and holds to control or submit
your opponent striking you striking uses
punches kicks knees elbows headbutts
or any other body part to hit the
opponent martial arts with weapons
obviously use utilize a variety of
weapons including sticks knives and in
the modern world firearms perhaps the
most
most critical form of self-defense is
the mind
by being smart and aware you can avoid
situations that are likely to expose you
to danger that being said there are
times
when your mind and your intelligence can
no longer help you
that is the reality so that's why we
train right
because there's as much as someone says
well you know i i'm able to avoid to
look there's gonna be situations that
you can end up in even if you're
completely situational aware and you're
looking to avoid situations they can
still happen
that's why you have to train i'm going
to skip ahead a little bit here
because i talk about firearms
and the the necessity of firearms
in certain situations and and i say this
most important without proper training
possessing a firearm is useless and or
even more dangerous to its owner than
not having one learning how to shoot
quickly and accurately while under
stress
is absolutely mandatory if one is going
to own a firearm
this means finding a good instructor at
a quality range to participate in
firearms training
right so you you gotta have a firearm
and i'm gonna go back and read a section
that i wasn't planning to read but i'm
gonna read it anyways
um
it is an eek the firearm the ultimate
form of self-defense is the firearm
it is an equalizer without parallel and
is simply unmatched in its ability to
eliminate an attacker regardless of size
and strength if a person truly needs
self-protection in a high threat area
there is no
substitute for the firearm even in an
area that might be considered low threat
there are no guarantees
there have been horrific home invasions
carjackings kidnappings and
other vicious and violent attacks in
some of the most prestigious
neighborhoods in the world
that were also considered to be the
safest there is no choice but to be
prepared
so firearms
talk about some of the training and what
you do and you know some of the some of
the benefits of it firearms training
builds hand-eye coordination speed
concentration and instincts it demands
repetitive movement develop muscle
memory
so there's there's other benefits to to
utilizing firearms than just
self-protection training competitively
for speed and accuracy conditions you
for high pressure situations
by teaching the need to relax detach and
get control of your breathing and focus
on the immediate task like you can apply
that to anything
not just a shooting so there's some some
real benefits
to firearms and then i go on here but
firearms are not always available
there are many places in the world where
carrying a gun is illegal there are also
times where firearms malfunction it is
also important to know how to defend
yourself in unarmed situations
which brings us back to martial arts
first let me say that the martial arts
are very emotional for some people
their martial art becomes their religion
and they become blinded by it
martial arts are not static they evolve
all
with they evolve all the time if you do
not evolve with them
you will be left behind picking one
martial art versus another or saying
that one martial art is
better than another martial art drive
some people crazy
i do not engage in irrational
theoretical discussions on which
martial art is best there's no reason to
theorize anymore
the ultimate fighting championship put
many theories to the test
the wars in iraq and afghanistan also
put many theories to the test
about hand-to-hand combat finally every
person now carries a video camera in
their pocket
and there are thousands of street fights
and confrontations to watch on the
internet
with all that information readily
available there is no need to theorize
anymore
it is easy to see what works and what
doesn't furthermore
it is also obvious that martial arts are
not stagnant they evolve
people develop new techniques and new
moves to counter other techniques and
other moves
but they but the fundamental principles
do not change they only become
reinforced
and i give some advice here start with
brazilian jiu jitsu
it is a form of grappling that is highly
advanced because for the most part the
actual fighting takes place on the
ground
this is a key point because our first
form of self-defense is to get away
yes run if you are confronted by another
person
or a group of people the best thing you
can do is run away avoid the conflict
this is relatively easy if someone is
trying to strike with you
or strike you with punches or kicks they
do not have control over you
so you can simply run away from them you
have one
the problem comes in a self-defense
situation when someone is grabbing you
now they are preventing your first line
of defense running
as soon as someone grabs you you are in
a grappling scenario
and one of the most critical parts of
brazilian jiu jitsu is escaping
someone's grip so you can run oftentimes
an attacker will take you to the ground
in order to prevent you from escaping
their grip when this happens the ability
to ground fight is used not to stay on
the ground
but to get up and get away from the
attacker the first
goal of a beginner in jiu jitsu is not
to get the fight to the ground
but to get up off the ground and get
away this is an important distinction
from people who believe the goal of
self-defense in jiu-jitsu
is to get the attacker to the ground
this is not true
the goal is to get away but as has been
seen
over and over again fights often end up
on the ground and therefore a person
must be prepared for it
not training in jiu jitsu because you
don't want to go to the ground is like
not learning to swim because you don't
want to go in the water
it doesn't make sense the safest way to
deal with the water is to be comfortable
in it
just as being comfortable on the ground
is the best way to deal with that
scenario
should it unfold in real life
questions comments from echo charles
i agree we can reach back to your days
many days
on the front lines of the bouncing work
sure uh yeah i agree that is yeah i
agree i can't disagree at all one of the
one of the primary arguments that people
give when they
you know brazilian jiu-jitsu is no good
for self-defense why would you take
someone to the ground why are you taking
them around that's not we're not doing
that we're trying to get away yeah so
you know after like at the monster when
we do the jiu-jitsu part
and you notice this and you actually
pointed it out which i liked
but whatever where i said if i choose to
fight this guy you know like i'll go
through the basic thing or whatever i
come from this guy's conference me and i
choose to fight him so it's way
different than self-defense
that's like i chose to fight this person
and most of the time you you add in just
like i said earlier where
if you don't have a choice to run like
if i grab you or whatever there's that
too for sure
but yes if you choose to fight him then
yeah you
can take him to a ground or whatever now
your choice to fight him is gonna be
based on a bunch of other things and it
better be intelligent because if you're
like yeah
i'm at the club you said this and
whatever and then you choose to fight on
that
yeah i don't know if that's an you know
the right choice and now you got a whole
different issue
than the self-defense situation you know
that's like a choice that you made or
whatever but yeah
if you're you know i don't know fighting
with your friend
not your friend but your enemy after
school and everyone's like circle i
don't know whatever there there's
there's choices to be made and if the
right choice is to fight the guy then
yes
bring those shits well then yeah so so
then you can use
jiu-jitsu but now you're using it in an
offensive situation
so yes you probably will want to take
the person to the ground yeah absolutely
i mean if it's if it's a like a
one-on-one i'm choosing to fight because
if it's
four on one and you're choosing to fight
you're just being stupid yes you're
about to get your ass beat
yes sir yeah the very high likelihood
yes yeah
i do have a question about the firearms
train like you know how you
train in stressful situations what kind
of stressful situations can you
like put yourself in or whatever uh
there's some obvious ones the most
obvious one is time constraints so hey i
want to get these shots off as quick as
possible and i'm competing against you
know
echoes going against me and we're trying
to see who wins there's a little bit of
stress there but also hey
do 30 burpees and then shoot six head
plates
right good so you're breathing hard
sprint reload reload drills
um this all those things that that
just there's a million different ways
yeah i mean you can i'm sure those were
enough to kind of spark your creativity
on what you could do to make it
stressful
yeah fully the time because i went it
was the last
time i went but i i went to the range
with keenan cornelius
and we did we just did like a simple fun
like contest
you know kind of like shooting we play
horse yeah
kind of like that kind of situation i
mean i actually filmed it but the video
kind of got wonky i was going to release
it but that
that did add a little something because
it like if you miss or you whatever it
meant something kind of thing but
it i didn't i'd never felt i wouldn't
label it as a stressful
training scenario but time constraints
if it's like okay you've got time and
you're just trying to get better at it
competition i mean when you're in the
seal teams you're doing freaking
competitive shooting against every
basically all the time you're shooting
against somebody
or you're shooting against three people
or four people or whatever so
you you're you you have that level of
stress but then it's also you know
you're gonna run you're gonna run up
that berm you're gonna drag that tire
you're gonna come back over here you're
gonna shoot six headplates you're gonna
go back you're gonna get on your long
gun you're gonna put down this one
you've got all these things that you got
to do and it's all a race and they're
just trying to make you freak out and
then on top of that
you know once you get into simunition
now you've got you you're not shooting
real bullets but you're shooting you got
people maneuvering you got people
you know you're throwing flash classes
we got grenades going off like all kinds
of mayhem
and simunition is just as loud as
regular it's not just as loud no
is it like night and day like night and
day yeah no kidding okay cause that
i feel like and obviously i've never
been in a straight-up gun fight with
anyone like they're shooting at me i'm
shooting at them
but i would imagine
that just hearing other gunshots
going on and you know that they're at
you or intended for you or whatever
that's going to just bring you out of
your whole shooting game
yeah the noise of gunshots it's like
if you hear it a lot less when you're
when you're shooting like at somebody in
the
you're in the game yeah like it's a lot
less
a lot less um it's not that it's not
like the
like the little shock that you get when
you're at the range or whatever
okay even even actually if you get
you know you get like a good stress
scenario going even in a training
situation you won't really like notice
big time and we used to do
our drills this was back in the you know
[Music]
they used to man this is this is i don't
recommend it but they would make us do
some of our
immediate action drills with no uh ear
protection in
so that we would like quote get used to
it yeah but
it's loud yeah so and that was
something too that i was wondering where
so if you're in the field straight up
or zone do you have ear protection yeah
you have well
nowadays we have this and this is
another thing that's pretty
crazy is we have the headsets that are
noise canceling headsets
and the reason you're wearing them is
because you're on the radio so it's it's
your
headphone for your radio so you can hear
and it's a noise-canceling headset so
when a loud noise goes off it cancels
out that noise
yeah so so okay so
when was the first time you ever shot a
gun do you remember in my life yeah in
your life i was probably like
eight or nine i think okay maybe ten
yeah some no i think i think i was
younger than ten
but i was uh i was up in maine and i
went out to uh my friend my
friend was a little bit older than me uh
we went out to his
uncle's farm and shot yeah
so the so you weren't like
surprised by how freaking loud a gun is
then
no but i think i think what you're
getting at is
people that i don't really remember
enough of like my introduction of
firearms
to get what you're getting at which is
firearms are freaking loud
way louder than anything they could
portray in the movies or whatever
yeah 100 yeah because that it just again
i
never been in a firefight but it just
seems like when you imagine it where
when it kicks off and
you didn't kick it off with the first
shot if someone else
shot the first shot it seems like you'd
just be
out of the game if you're not used to it
yeah well you definitely that's another
thing is you get so used
to gunshots
in the seal teams from your training
that
that doesn't really like it's not a
shock anymore
yeah you're so accustomed to it it's not
it's not shocking it's like oh yeah
that's true oh where's that coming from
right yeah even like when you're also
the distance you know when someone's
a little bit further away from you the
the shock is a lot less when you get
away from it
you know the concussion of the shot
yeah now if they're in the same room as
you it can be pretty
pretty dynamic right for sure we should
ask mike
day oh yeah how'd that go yeah
yeah man yeah it's crazy like when okay
so when you go to the gun range let's
say
you know it's your first time or
whatever the gun range when you walk in
that door
and you hear other people shooting
you're like yeah bro okay so have you
shot outdoors yet
yeah yeah okay because it's a lot
different shooting outdoors than indoors
yeah a lot different
yeah yeah i don't think i even it was
actually the first time i shot a
gun i think one of the early times
anyway was
was outdoors and i don't think we even
had ear protection
and depending on the gun i mean some
guns aren't really that big of a deal
yeah we were shooting the like uh some
louder ones
okay 45 shotgun for we're shooting clay
clay pigeons or whatever um and
yeah i remember them being loud like for
real loud even outdoors but
compared to indoors it's it was nothing
because if you don't wear ear protection
like at the regular indoor gun range
like
you might have issues yeah you got
issues for sure
but it's good to condition it's good to
stress condition it's good to get used
to those noises it's good to get used to
all those things this is what is what we
train for
and we should not just relegate training
to just being in the military we should
train
for you know other things that can
happen in life and if you are going to
have a firearm you
damn well better train with it
um going back to the jujitsu thing i
want to read this other little section
another reason i recommend starting
martial arts by learning brazilian jiu
jitsu is because it is the most complex
of the martial arts
although there is a finite number of
moves and positions there is an
infinite number of moves beyond the
basics
and more developed every day in this
constantly
evolving art due to this unending depth
in jiu-jitsu it is also the most
cerebral
of martial arts it provides incredible
mental stimulus
and a never-ending challenge to learn
develop and improve
jiu-jitsu never gets old the next
martial art i recommend is learning
boxing boxing is incredibly effective
striking art despite its relative
simplicity there are only two weapons in
boxing
the left hand and the right hand but
with those two weapons an incredible
advantage can be gained if you know how
to throw them in effective combinations
other critical elements learned in
boxing are angles movement
both of which are based heavily on
footwork and speed which is
which are utilized in both free both the
offense and defense of boxing
with basic boxing knowledge a person can
throw effective punches and avoid being
punched
both extremely useful assets when
attempting to attempting the primary
goal of self-defense
run boxing develops the ability to hit
quickly avoid being hit
and run away from the area of
confrontation
so that's just regular western boxing
and this is sort of like again this is
my recommendation if you're starting
from ground zero and you know nothing
this is how i would go about it
there can be some argument made that if
you were going to a place tomorrow
that you needed to be ready to get
attacked
then maybe like you'd look at some other
form of martial arts
but if if that's your situation like
it's not smart
i mean and you know by that i mean some
of these i i don't even know if that's a
true statement
yeah i mean it's what i i think it might
be i think it is one of the statements
where it just straight up depends
so it depends on what you mean you're
going to be attacked like just by a
person and is that person be trained or
no
untrained are they bigger than you or
they can be equal size of you know or
smaller or weapons or yeah
and then it depends on who like okay you
might learn
you know and what is it like okay you
might need these these kind of blitz
martial arts type situation like a krav
maga yeah you know
or whatever or whatever some cool system
whatever narita actually told me that i
think narita was like you know if you
had like one day
i would teach somebody some basic krav
maga yeah and and
that could be true for sure if you know
if the t the instructor is teaching you
for that reason
yeah you just got one day let's pack it
in or
and then even a jiu jitsu scenario
here's the problem with that statement
now that i think through it
in my opinion the problem with that
statement is if you really think that
that one day is going to help you
you're an idiot like it might be the
best you could do but it only going to
give you a one percent better chance
than
you know so don't get yourself in that
situation that's why you make martial
arts a part of your life
yeah it's got to be a life thing yeah
but the thing is that is a thing though
where like even tim ferriss sort of
studies it a little bit remember like
because he took a thing a jujitsu thing
where he was like hey i need to know
that the most
that i possibly can to be effective in
this small short oh this was like a tv
show right it was yeah it was like one
of his things
and i was like oh that's an interesting
theory because that's not
the way you trained jiu jitsu at all and
you know they taught him like
the guillotine was one of them that they
taught because there's not all these
like factors you have to kind of
establish before you can execute the
move or
not as many or whatever that was kind of
the thing and
anyway the point is it introduced like
an interesting approach
to these things this real short-term
approach how can i get the most
effectiveness out of it if i only have a
short amount of time
rather than infinite time you know so
yeah but yeah
that's cool too because you could also
that would be it'd be if you made
if someone said i'm gonna go to this
place tomorrow and there's a high
likelihood i got attacked
i would be taking i wouldn't i would be
taking very small parts of various
martial arts
yeah that's what i think i would do but
again i don't want to make that sound
like it's a solution because i don't
want to sound like the freaking
magazines that say
defeat any attacker three moves it's
a lie straight up it's a lie straight up
don't think of it that way don't even
forget i just said that
yeah here's the deal make martial arts a
part of your life
that's what you need to do back to the
book the next two martial arts to invest
time into are muay thai and wrestling
they both add a plethora of options and
skills to any fighter
wrestling wrestling is a grappling art
perhaps the most widely known and
practiced look i go through a bunch of
stuff
i talk about muay thai and muay thai is
awesome
i think the reason that i put that i
would train someone in boxing first
before muay thai it's just for the
complexities
like muay thai is just that much more
complex you can throw elbows you can
throw knees you can throw kicks there's
a lot more
things to learn yeah so the first thing
i want to learn is how to throw hands
you know how to throw hands get head
movement get angles
work distance like that's all going to
come from just boxing without
opening up because look i mean muay thai
is savage
bro muay thai is savage
yeah that's one and it's pain that's
what i was gonna say like that's what
you get taught
as well and not like a secondary
teaching
like one of the primary thinking is like
kind of how fragile you are with pain
where the kind of like okay or how much
you can get used to it too
exactly right that's part of the
training you know that's what you do
benefit from taking that pain like ribs
legs is a huge one man like a leg kick
body kick punch even when you kick
somebody
and it lands in the wrong spot it's like
it hurts
it's it's worse than
most hits that you get like if you get
punched in the face let's face it i mean
it seems crazy or whatever but it
doesn't hurt that much
even if you really get a good one it
more knocks you like dizzy more than it
actually
is pain pain muay thai is straight up
pain
in fact in a way sometimes you kind of
wish you'd stop
punching me below the freaking neck
or kicking or whatever just punch me in
the face that's way better way more
is relief really you know sometimes but
yeah you get used to that and that kind
of training is very beneficial
because men you kick even in like a real
fight or whatever you give
if you can effectively like like kick
somebody
two even three times or something like
this and they feel that pain they would
be like bro
you're watching the ufc you're like oh
you know what the guy got kicked on the
leg you think no big deal
you're you don't know no here actually i
was like trying to think what did i say
muay thai adds a massive arsenal of
striking options to a fighter where
boxing utilizes only two fists muay thai
utilizes fist elbows knees
and the shins in very aggressive
combinations that are absolutely
devastating in a fight
muay thai is also about pain and the
ability to withstand
pain yes sir legit
uh talk about chain conditioning in
there so definitely
look muay thai awesome wrestling clearly
is just freaking awesome um
wrestling is a grappling heart the
physical grind of wrestling hardens the
body and mind without mercy
on top of the conditioning and mental
toughness derived from wrestling it is
also the king of position in martial
arts and we see this from the ufc this
is why
this is why the wrestlers dominate in
the ufc meaning a good wrestler can
decide
what position they will be in during a
confrontation no other martial art
provides the practitioner
a better ability to dictate the position
of a fight with one simple idea
the main focus of wrestling is to get
the opponent to the ground and keep them
there
so then i say once a good base is
and again there's a bunch of details on
wrestling on muay thai unboxing
once a good base is established in
brazilian jiu jitsu boxing wrestling and
muay thai
there are plenty of other martial arts
to explore
judo is a fantastic art and has very
effective takedowns especially against
an opponent wearing a jacket or shirt
um [ __ ] i talk about
krav maga i talk about screamer and kali
and the dog brothers you know the dog
brothers
vaguely yes yeah the dog brothers are
legit
about as legit as it gets they and
they've been around for a long time
but for those of you that don't know the
dog brothers
they would have these fights with
weapons and basically you would wear the
guys would wear
like lacrosse gloves i guess to protect
their fingers
and they would wear some kind of some
kind of like hockey helmet
to protect their heads and then they
would use various weapons
they would use sticks they would use
chains
they would use canes just all and they
would go at it like they would fight
like they would fight and you could tap
out but they were gonna fight you were
gonna get
hit and you can go watch those videos of
the dog brothers but what was cool about
it is
they've been around for a very long time
and it was the most
realistic you know it's the most
realistic weapons fighting
i think that then that i've seen and
and then they would try and learn from
it and all that so
very cool stuff that they taught and
trained in and then i say the list could
go on and on there's
there's no reason to ever stop training
and learning martial arts
of course it is good to be prepared to
handle a self-defense situation
but the benefits of martial arts
training go far beyond self-defense of
course you get physically conditioned
you also get mentally tougher real
martial arts are hard they
they are a mental and physical grind
if the martial art you are training in
is easy
it isn't likely doing much good martial
arts
also get you used to being on
uncomfortable situations and continuing
to fight on
this is important in any endeavor
martial arts will make you better
so train don't think about it don't take
time to get in shape before you start
just go start the rest will come and
then i have a whole section in here
about
where to train what type of academy what
are you looking for thank god the world
is
improving where there's jiu-jitsu
everywhere now look we're going to get
through this covered thing here shortly
and all the jiu-jitsu gyms will be back
open
i have a section in here on immediate
action drills
facing a threat so it's like talking
about what you actually do
when bad things are happening you know
we get
mass shooting situations we got all
kinds of problems out there
and you know i wanted to talk about how
you handle those
situations um
the next section man i hit every
controversial the this next act is
called feeding the machine
and the first section here and by the
way you know everyone's going to comment
about
you know what's funny is like people
comment you know we've had some
some some excerpts put out from us
talking about martial arts and there's
people that would say
would call out certain things and i'll
read through the comments oh yes well
that's actually accurate yeah i did you
know i shouldn't have said that right
i didn't mention that or whatever so if
you're going to get all
ham if you get all ham in the comments
go for it and uh we'll maybe we'll
address them on the grounded podcast but
um some good points are made in there
and and like i said these are
these are if if you consider your
martial art a religion
and something that i said attacked your
religion if you're
a die-hard muay thai and you think that
i'm saying that jiu-jitsu is better to
you know like and you want to bring it
i'm sorry i mean
it's just this is my thoughts you can
disagree that's cool
muay thai is awesome wrestling's awesome
boxing's awesome jiu jitsu is awesome
i i love them all train them all
it's all good um but it's controversial
for some people
yes some people it's a religion so you
gotta be careful that
uh so when talking about
fuel like what we are going to
eat this is another thing that can
become
you know kind of controversial and
people get crazy on
i got a section here says addicted to
sugar
sugar is truly addictive it stimulates
the same parts of the brain as heroin
and cocaine when you have it
you want more of it and you know this to
be true
that's why you can't stop eating it and
when you do stop eating it
you will feel withdrawal headache
irritation anxiety lies
the lies will come and they will come
from you the lies
you tell yourself are it's no big deal i
can just have a little
it isn't worth it to feel this bad the
body needs carbs
you will rationalize and start to listen
to lies don't stay strong get off the
sugar train
get off the addiction stop eating sugar
cocaine and heroin people
don't you know what the rats eat
uh fuel look i talk about
i talk about what to eat and and again
this is a religion for some people for a
lot of people it's a religion
i kind of you know hey here's what i
think here's what i eat
you know i eat these things beef poultry
fish eggs nuts
vegetables fungi
roots some dairy limited fruit so if you
want to get crazy on that cool
you want to attack me cool what kind of
fungi you eat
mushrooms i guess and ringworm i guess
[Laughter]
i'll have a double ringworm sandwich
please
uh don't eat these grains potatoes
refined salt refined sugar processed
oils
right so it's just basic stuff
let's not get crazy
fasting talk about fasting this section
starts off news flash you don't have to
eat
fasting is a gift actually my daughter
my wrestling my middle daughter that
wrestled
she told me she would think about this
because when she would be cutting weight
she'd be thinking she would think but i
talk about in here you know
the human body can live for a long time
here we go humans can survive 30 days
without food you can make it an extra
few hours
you can actually make it a few days
without any issue i fast 24 hours
regularly i do 72 hours
fast approximately every three months
and you know what they aren't that big
of a deal
when i'm fasting i still do everything i
would normally do if i were eating i
work i work out i train jiu jitsu
i drink water some tea maybe eat some
sunflower seeds
freak out you're not fasting you ate a
sunflower seed that's what i do
like take it easy uh
so i have something to chew on but
fasting isn't that hard and you will
feel better at the end of it
this is my favorite thing fasting will
recalibrate what hunger is to you
you'll realize that you aren't actually
hungry most of the time
you're just bored and at the end of a
fast your food will taste better too
that is a factual beautiful thing
food tastes good when you uh when you do
that
so a whole section on fasting and a
bunch of benefits from that
got a section here dealing with injuries
and
illness you are going to get
injured you are going to get sick
regardless of how careful you are
in training how clean you eat and how
healthy you live
you are still human injuries and illness
will occur my theory for overcoming
injuries and illness is simple do what
you can
if you're sick or injured don't use that
as an excuse to skip workouts or stay in
bed all day do what you can
hurt your knee work your upper body work
the good leg
hurt your shoulder time to work on one
arm pull ups and push-ups
focus on your core and legs until your
shoulder heals up
tendonitis from using your grip too much
sounds like it's time to focus on
sprinting and jumping and
plyometrics got a little cold flu same
thing
do what you can maybe just going for a
walk a couple sets of sit-ups and
push-ups but don't just stay in bed all
day
now sometimes you get plain knocked out
by illness or a virus
if it is that bad and your body
absolutely needs rest
good listen to your body and take the
rest
also don't bring your disease to the gym
and spread it around work out at home
same thing with injuries if some injury
prevents you from doing the physical
things you like to do
good do what you can work on some skills
you can do pick up a guitar write a book
draw
paint compose a song blog create
learn do something take advantage of
physical injuries and sickness
by doing something you don't normally
have time for in other words get after
it
and i recently did that when i got
covered
i was like oh cool i can't i can't
literally leave my house
apparently right the rules not supposed
to interact with anybody
so and everybody kind of knew i had it
so i was like cool and i just like
played guitar a bunch
and started digging into a bunch i've
been
i've been playing guitar for 35 years
and i've been at the same level for
about 34 and a half years
and in the past two weeks
i've advanced tenfold on my
understanding of
star so this isn't just me saying this
it's actually
something to do the more you do that too
the more you get used to that protocol
you know
where you know how like sometimes like
your workouts or your whatever
is like that's like your your main jam
like
and then you get hurt and then you're
all you know you can
get depressed or just be so unhappy that
you're out of game can't train jiu jitsu
and people get off it's awful
but if you're used to that protocol
where it's like it it essentially
opens up opportunity for new
developments and growth you know for
yourself
literally making you a better person
right so if that becomes a protocol a
normal protocol when you get injured
it's automatic you're like okay i'm
injured hey
whatever junk but whatever and then this
protocol kind of ensues
and then boom you're kind of like you're
kind of into that for a little bit yeah
because
getting injured
it's for people like you for people like
me that are
really like do physical stuff getting
injured is so horrible
yeah but i i i will say i have this
protocol
where i'm like oh cool uh when i when i
do you remember when i hurt my elbow
like dean
i mean i was in a sling i've never been
a sling in my life but like
the next day or maybe it was one day
later like at first i couldn't even do
anything yeah but then i was in doing
one arm kettlebell
swing and snatches and stuff i was like
okay cool we're just gonna work through
this
it'll get better over time that's what
it's going to take but whatever it's
like a cut like you couldn't play guitar
though
dang bro brutal the uh the initiating
like the first thing you do is
essentially
see what you can do and can't do it and
then from there you just go forward
where it's like yeah you do what you can
physically but we know that's not gonna
it's hard to be like mentally on that
same level
as far as like your enthusiasm to pursue
workouts or jiu-jitsu whatever when
you're just doing what you can do
especially if it's a significant injury
but if you can do this other stuff
now you know you can focus on other
stuff or whatever you have like yeah
then you just get a new mission who you
are a new mission new mission
new mission straight up um
there's a whole section like i said
appendix is just
all kinds of workouts from beginner
workouts that literally any human being
can do
to advance workouts that will crush
whoever
and they're all written down in there
and then
well let me just read the last page of
this book let's give it away
the spoiler cheer spoiler the section's
called
do and it says don't just read this book
don't just listen to the podcast don't
just
watch videos online don't just
take notes don't just study them don't
just share them with your friends
don't just plan don't just mark your
calendar
don't just get motivated don't
just talk don't just think
don't just dream no
none of that matters the only thing that
matters is that you
actually do
so do
and there you go that's that's the book
and
you know i think that this book
obviously as i started off this book is
something that anyone
can use it's something that i actually
use something that i have used in dire
situations to help me
and something i use on a daily situation
to help me something that
something that we could all use
to look at to remind us to keep us on
the path it's a very
presence sends a message do you like
that
it's very presence sends a message yeah
i do like that thank you just there it's
looking at you
sending a message and the message is
discipline equals freedom
so get after it so
echo we we want to get after it
do you have any recommendations on how
we do that or how we can keep doing that
but this book is like the ultimate
like new year's book
you know people they'll make like the
new year's resolutions
you know but usually because you know
how they say like a lot of
most whatever i don't know that number
like resolutions they'll fail after
whatever amount of time
seven days yeah something yeah
but think when you think about it when
you have the manual
you don't have to it doesn't have to
fail like you just refer to the manual
it's a you know it's a good thing rather
than let's face it
it was
like when you make a new year's
resolution it's kind of like oh i just
sort of intend to get in shape you don't
have a path a plan
you don't actually know what's your deal
yeah you just have any intention
boom you got it right there you know
it's like one of those things
in fact i would argue that if you're
like okay this is my kind like i was
saying with the owner's manual of a car
if you just if you have this and you
treat it as your owner's manual for your
new year's resolution or for your life
in general
it should be for your life in general
yes but i'm saying if you want to slide
it in and have it serve that
particular purpose for the moment i like
get
you know what i think is cool is giving
it to someone
give the gift of discipline
give the gift of discipline this one was
freedom field manual
mark one motto oh by the way the name of
this is mark one motto that's from
the military term it's when they modify
things
sure so mark one is like this is the
first model of it then
mod one is the first modification the
first mod that they make
so there's a modification to this one my
head is bigger on the cover
yeah that's a mod right there wait wait
wait wait what is mark one what is
mark one is it's like a m it's like a
model number
yeah but they just call it a mark yeah
it's in the navy
yeah well it's in cameras as well so you
got the canon so canon
5d mark i'm going to the ones that i
have mark one
okay so canon 5d mark one then there's
mark two and then there's mark three
got it yeah so they could have said mark
one
and if they made like small changes to
it probably mod one
if they did like a full revamp then it's
mark two yeah
yeah so you could get you know a weapon
system
sure that is the mark one it's the but
then they add a
new front sight to it you're like okay
this is mark 1 mod 1.
and then they add a new rear sight and
it's like oh mark 1 mod 2.
so you can keep doing that so this this
field manual
and what's cool i will say i i have a
lot of
what is it creative control so my
publisher i said yeah it's gonna be mark
one model one
what's they're like they didn't have any
idea what this is i might as well say
the google blue
all right they have no idea what i'm
talking about but they go with it yeah
so credit
it does sound cool mark one mod one yeah
well i'm glad you think it sounds cool
better than tactical uh what
the uh mark okay so you you would
actually not to spend go too deep on
this mark one mod one
workings but okay so what what's a cause
you said
the guns before something mark one like
what which gun
no we don't the guns are actually an
army weapon system mark is from like the
navy
yeah but you like what was the
okay what machine gun did you carry y
m4 m4 there you go that was one oh yeah
in the army it's just
m though it's not mark oh so m4 is mark
four
no no m4 is the gun and then it's mark
one no they don't they don't do it with
guns they just say it's
it's like more of a navy term gotcha
well they do it with cameras straight up
they have a boat called the mark 5.
okay all right well i'm gonna leave that
to the navy
and the weapon system scenario and
cameras by the way because uh i don't
know if i have
grasp on it yet but i'll tell you what i
do have a grasp on is how we can all
stay
stay on the path or get on the path if
you're not on the path already
when you're on the path you're gonna
find out that it's hard it's not always
easy
it's actually not even always hard
technically
but it does get hard from time to time
sometimes you need assistance
sometimes you need supplementation it's
true
jocko has us covered choco fuel okay so
if you if
your joints are in need of
supplementation we've got joint
supplements
joint warfare it's what's called this
first one
super krill oil it's the second one
for your joints boom you want to blend
into immunity stuff
we got vitamin d three
also cold war boom joints
immunity covered don't even think about
those anymore put that into your daily
discipline routine every morning or
every night whatever
boom you don't got to worry about that
kind of stuff anymore also
discipline and discipline go now this is
a
cognitive supplement similar to what
sleep does
really you talked about brain derived
nootropic
factor number 99 or whatever you're
saying
it's kind of the same thing this is
number 100 100
mark 100 over here either way it's kind
of the same thing
really yeah 100 bro
coming at me with some hardcore bro
science i hit you with bro science today
you're coming back at me i like it
hey man it's part of the game it's all
part of the game nonetheless so
discipline doesn't go you know enhance
your
mind helps your cognitive abilities and
physical abilities by the way
many different modes that you um what
does it term you oh get you primed
oh yeah right is that what the word you
said primed get the cognitive physical
mental priming going on
can you get a can of discipline go get
the get the pill get the powder
so before workouts i like the powder
for that priming effect because there's
there's regular priming and then there's
like the secondary priming effect maybe
or
maybe more accurately put the
psychological
priming effect because you mix up the
little
discipline mix mega mix
whatever mix it up and when you're
drinking it it's like your mind is just
getting ready ready psychologically not
to mention all the physiological
benefits i'm saying so it's like one on
top of the other anyway
it's part of the game but if you want to
replace your current energy drink
problem
that's what it is oh it definitely is no
not even potentially
it's straight up it's a problem if
you're drinking energy drinks
normal energy it's a problem okay it's a
problem because you're getting sugar
you're getting an overdose of caffeine
you're getting a bunch of chemicals in
there that they use to preserve that
there's
it's it is a absolutely it's a problem
yeah i was
yeah okay i was gonna talk about this
you know i'm gonna do it
i'm gonna talk about it so anyway my
kids watch this show
it's called the victorious the show
you'll never
know this show ever yep i no no your
youngest daughter might actually
watch it okay you said i will never know
it and i said yes i will not i might not
know you might over
hear it or whatever anyway it's kind of
a funny little show called victorious uh
ariana grande is in it and tor
tory don't look at me for help come on
come on you know you know tory son
anyway they're perfect anyway um and so
here's
here's the thing here's the issue with
all their not the issues the complex
story
kind of i'm trying to remember why
you've been brought up but okay okay
this is why so
every time there's like a brand in there
they do a real odd they do a good job
but it's real
obvious what brand they're portraying
but like okay they'll have an apple
computer but
and it looks like an apple computer but
instead of an apple it's a pair yeah
so like instead of like air pods they'll
have pair pods you know like it's real
obvious right they do that with the
brands they'll have a generic version of
the brand just
throughout the show right one episode
there this one was actually kind of like
a little political episode almost
a little freedom situation so they had
this
drink it was soda called blue dog
blue dog drink and then a guy from the
fbi the federal
bureau of interference came in
and said hey we're getting rid of all
it's we're banning it prohibition style
we're taking off all the shelves and all
the kids waged
and before they waged this campaign
against hey it's if it's freedom you
know like people you know you shouldn't
ban it for everyone
just because certain people can't make
choices whatever good choices whatever
but what they did was they started
making their own knockoff red dog soda
and then they got busted and then anyway
it was a thing
right here's the thing here's a point i
hope so
we know what red or not red dogs sorry
blue dog
you know what brand they're portraying
yes i think that's pretty probably some
energy drink scenarios going
on right that's what they're talking
about um so
with our current in real life
energy during scenario hey we have the
freedom to drink whatever we want to
drink
but i think it would benefit everyone
including yourself
to make the right choice with that
freedom
now if energy drinks are your weakness
hey that's no problem now
now it's not a problem you just switch
over to the discipline go in a can
fulfills all the good energy drink
criteria and there's not many but it
fulfills all of them which is
you get some energy from it but now
instead of killing yourself
at the same time literally by the way
slowly literally
you're helping yourself and improving
your health
well i would love to add something to
this but uh
no one's listening anymore
you can get this stuff at
origenmaine.com you can get this stuff
at
the vitamin shop you can get this stuff
out you can get the drinks at wawa by
the way we'll be live
in wawa whole east coast every store
january 4th epic that's due in large
part
to troopers in florida that went into
the wawas
and cleared shelves keep it up
keep it up because from wawa when when
other stores see what we're doing in
wawa
we'll get nationwide so now east coast
west coast
if you're on the east coast and you're
going to wawa clear it out
support so that way west coast stores
who knows which one it'll be
that well they'll get it in there and
we'll start to do what we what we like
to call
a world takeover get rid of it and we
will get rid of blue dog
yeah blue dunk and the rest of them with
their weird
colors we don't want to rely on the
federal bureau of
interference to get rid of unhealthy
stuff
we just do it oh we're gonna make the
market do it yes making good decisions
that's what we want to do
well it's also milk protein in the form
of a dessert
straight up my little son's four years
old said
can i have some milk out of the blue
it's like sure i'm not gonna argue with
that one gee do i want you to get
stronger
better smarter healthier let me think
about it yes i do
let's do this yes sir we do yes so
yeah get on that man some extra protein
when you're lifting
shoe that's a good deal also jacqueline
t
refreshing certified organic kind of
drinks as a matter of fact
if you notice that oh yeah i actually
chilly out here in california and for
those of you up in wisconsin by chili
i mean about 64 degrees that is
technically chilly yeah it's insane uh
i have i didn't notice you drinking that
you know why because you're always
drinking that stuff
and after a while you just don't notice
anymore it's kind of pretty in fact i
would probably not even recognize you if
you're not drinking that
kind of stuff nonetheless yes vitamin
chop wawa all available orgymay.com
available
all this stuff also on origenmaine.com
is jiu-jitsu stuff geez rash guards if
you're still doing jiu jitsu
right get out origin mingi well you
should be doing and if you heard me
talking about the jiu-jitsu today you
probably realize it's something you
should start immediately
then you're gonna need a ghee you're
gonna need some rash guards
and listen when you're not on the mats
of justice you're still going to need
clothing to wear you're going to need
things to put on your body
things to put on your your legs things
to put on your feet we got those things
too
we got delta jeans best jeans ever most
comfortable jeans ever
we got boots
oh yeah the boots do have a name lincoln
do you have lincoln boots
i don't know maybe the lincoln boots
have like a toe cap on them
uh wait what do you mean like a leather
an additional piece of
left piece of leather sewn over there
externally extra oh
damning yeah no no no no no other ones
are just called i forget what the other
i forget the name of the other ones
roosevelt no no no
no that's interesting pete you just got
an f
in product naming okay right
no p oh yeah because it's not memorable
why didn't i remember it
yeah i don't i don't know that those
last boots
had a name they had to have had a name
pete names
you know he likes that kind of stuff
right he names his parking spot
he names his parking spot it's like this
is the what would he name this parking
spot
this is the intergalactic parking space
of justice
brad the jeans funny so my birthday was
recently whatever
and my wife buys me some jeans so i'm
like cool
she's like i'm like hey i'm not gonna
you know i'm probably not gonna wear
this she's like well you need variety or
whatever
you only wear those origin jeans all the
time every single time we're using your
jeans so just some variety or whatever
so i'm like
whatever she's like hey don't be
ignorant and not try them on
okay so i'm like all right hey i don't
want to be ignorant okay i prefer not to
be ignorant we'll say that
so i try them on and i'm like okay they
fit good i'm not gonna wear these jeans
never wear these it's not the same why
would i ever wear some
non-origin jeans yeah at this point yeah
like i said the other day your iconic
jeans
that your wife got you for your birthday
they're made by
slave labor i mean
right so we're not supporting that we're
trying to rebuild america
it's hard yeah yeah so go to go to
origin maine.com if you want any of this
stuff if you want to help america
rebuild its manufacturing capability
we're doing it
and we appreciate everyone getting on
board supporting
and we're just the beginning we're just
the beginning so
thank you yes sir also jocko has a story
you want to represent while we
are on this path go to jackostore.com we
got some shirts discipline equals
freedom
shirts some good shirts
literally good shots literally they're
good and they say good on them and all
that stuff yeah yeah so and also get
after it you know these
shirts hoodies with hats shirts with
mantras on them i guess is what we're
getting
some mantra shirts for sure mr mantra
apparently but
technically it's we don't have too many
mantras
no it's you know it's the basic stuff
anyway it's
just a good way to represent got some
hats on there as well uh some women's
stuff
also on jocko jacostore.com
we have a exclusive i'm using that word
loosely but it's a club currently called
the t-shirt club okay i get we don't
like that name super original
yeah i made that name up too because i
was like i'm just going to deep into the
creative
zone i tried to pull it down the worst
name i've ever heard that's
that's weird how that backfired on me
huh what's weird is when
when i come up with a name that's sort
of like what it is
it's cool when you come up with a name
that's sort of what it is it's lame
yeah i mean like leadership strategy and
tactics field manual
that is the that is what this book is
this is the leadership
leadership strategy and tactics field
manual that's what the book is that's
what i called the book there you go
this one includes freedom field manual
yeah that what do we name the book
displays an equals freedom field manual
done
uh jocko white tea what do we call it oh
we're gonna call it white tea we're
gonna call it like
ancient whatever no we're calling it
choco white tea
so then you try this and it comes out
t-shirt club all right see and
here's the thing i mean you you didn't
have to say it like that you did
and that's fine but at the end of the
day you are correct
if i tried to pull a jock oh i'm not
chocolate straight up
no now you make me feel bad for beating
the defenseless child hey you're going
to feel how you're going to feel
you know but nonetheless it is a club it
is for t-shirts you get a shirt every
week
unique you can get discipline you can a
shirt every week
i'm sorry when it's okay i meant to say
unique and i said week
i meant month every month you get a
shirt they're they're different
than the discipline equals freedom
except for except
they do have hints and flavors of
discipline equals freedom in that one
anyway they're just a little bit
different a little bit cooler a little
bit
a few more layers on each one anyway if
you want to check it out it's a good one
um yeah t-shirt club on dracostore.com
you can get some of that warrior kid
soap there too yes sir from irish oaks
ranch
uh subscribe to the podcast if you
haven't we also got some other podcast
jocko unraveling
which used to be called the thread we
got the grounded podcast which we should
have just recorded when we were talking
with dean lish
yeah uh warrior kid podcast i know i oh
i know youtube channel
subscribe to the youtube channel if you
want to see echo charles's um
expressing himself through the through
the
visual medium of video and believe me
he is definitely doing that as as
to the extreme in many cases some keys
in some
cases exploring people's patience to
watch
cgi
yes i do technically i do explore
people's patients
okay a good way to put and i'm the
assistant director by the way and all
these things which is more important i
got an album called psychological
warfare
um it's an itunes album you can listen
to
me kind of just pulling you through some
maybe
scenarios of weakness that you might be
having might be having
and also this the book discipline
freedom field manual
is also available as an album that's we
we wanted you to be able to use it for
an alarm or just be able to press play
so that's on wherever you find your mp3s
and then don't forget about
dakotamyers.flipsidecanvas.com
selling a bunch of cool stuff to hang on
your wall that will keep you on the path
books got a bunch of books obviously
this one equals freedom field manual
this is the new version
this you can get it i think if you order
asap you can get it for
the holiday season give the gift of
discipline
no i shouldn't say like that give the
gift of discipline there we go
better give the gift of discipline
see you could could have made a cool
advertisement like that you can do
nothing
gonna be explosions there uh about face
by hackworth
leadership strategy and tactics field
manual the code the evaluation the
protocols
way the warrior kid four is also out
another field manual that's sort of like
the operating manual for a kid
you can get that you better order that
asap if that's going to come
for the christmas gift and once again
what the only thing better than
giving the gift of discipline to
yourself or your friends is giving the
gift of discipline to a kid
putting them on the right path that's
the way the warrior kid four field
manual
there's also way the warrior kid one two
and three there's also mike and the
dragons there's also extreme ownership
in the dichotomy leadership
we have echelon front which is a
leadership consultancy we solve problems
through leadership go to
echelonfront.com if you
want that we have ef online which is
totally revamped we're doing live q and
a's we got a forum on there we got
leadership primers we got immediate
action drills
we've got all kinds of things and i'm on
there all the time answering questions
so is the rest of the echelon front team
if you want to come check that out
efonline.com
we got the muster coming in 2021 phoenix
march 3rd and 4th orlando florida may
25th and 26th
and las vegas october 28th and 29th
check extremeownership.com
we're almost through with this covet
crap
the vaccines here these things
we didn't do any last year we canceled
all of them so everyone's going to come
this year they're going to sell out
come and get it ef overwatch if you need
executive leadership
inside your company then go to
efoverwatch.com
and if you want to help service members
active and retired if you want to help
their families if you want to help
gold star families then check out mark
lee's mom she's got a charity
organization
if you want to donate or you want to get
involved go to america's
mightywarriors.org
and if you just if you just feel the
need to suffer if that's what you're
feeling
well we can offer you that suffering if
you need if you need
more of my repressive rants or you need
more of echo's
perplexing quantifications and you
certainly got your share of those today
but if you want more
you can connect with us on the interwebs
on twitter on instagram
which is just so echo knows what i'm
talking about he calls it the gram and
on facebook
echo is adequate charles and i am at
jocko willink and thanks to all the
folks out there in uniform that are
protecting
the free world we are able to do what we
do because
of what you do and thanks to police and
law enforcement firefighters and
paramedics and emts and dispatchers and
correctional officers and border patrol
and secret service and all first
responders
your daily life is a sacrifice to keep
us safe
and secure here at home and we thank you
and to everyone else out there
we all want freedom
of course we all want freedom freedom is
the most
fundamental desire for human beings to
be able to do what we want to do
to have control over our own destiny we
want to be
free
but freedom true freedom
only comes from discipline so get
yourself on the path
get yourself on the path to health the
path to happiness
the path to success the path to freedom
and that path is the path of discipline
it
is the way of discipline get on it and
get after it
discipline equals freedom
and until next time this is echo and
jocko
out